COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVID NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
I WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ARTIST FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO TESTIFY. AND MAKE A
CREATE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. ACCESS CODE
SIX ONE NINE FOUR FOUR EIGHT.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT-PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU AN A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL BE PUT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. IS
NOTE THAT IN ORDER TO FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY INTO AVOID-
STICK FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. OVER THE PHONE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. ALSO MAINTAIN DECORUM
DOESN'T DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS NEEDED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE AS A MATTER. OF
CUSTOMARY. THE MAYBE LAG TIMES
FOR SOME PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE. OF
ONLINE TECHNOLOGIES AND TOOLS
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT. NOW LET'S GET STARTED
WITH THE BUSINESS OF THE
COMMITTEE BY ESTABLISHING. FOR
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SEVEN
DOLLARS. HERE IS ALWAYS HERE TO.
IT'S HERE ALANA MARCH ELEVENTH
MARCH LETTER HERE BECKER- HERE
CORTESE POTATO HERE VALLEY.
COLLEGE HERE THOUGHT HA WHERE.
MELINDA'S IN IN HERE NEWMAN
NEWMAN HERE. SCANNER NUMBER
NUMBERED HERE MY CASKET. WHAT
WILL PRESENT. YOU HAVE A- THANK
YOU MISTER SHE CONSULTANTS A
MEMBERSHIP NINE BILLS TODAY FOR
BILLS ON CONSENT FIVE BILLS UP
TODAY- THE FIRST IS THAT WE
HAVE THE HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE
THE FOLLOWING BILLS AND CONSENT
EIGHTY SIX OH FOUR BY DAILY AC
ARE NINETEEN BY GALLAGHER IS
HERE TWENTY ONE MEGAN DOLLY
ACER TWENTY SEVEN GALLAGHER
DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY OBJECTION.
TO ANY BILL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. HEARING NONE IS THERE
A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MOVED BY SENATOR
NEWMAN MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CENTER
GONZALES HI ANGELA HI BAIT. HI
ALAN. MARCH ELEVENTH ARCHULETA
HI BECKERBECKER HIGH CORTESE
CORTESE HI DOLLY. KELLY HI DOT.
MCGUIRE MELINDA'S MAN MAN HI
NEWMAN WOMEN ARE REBUILT.
SKINNER HUMBERT HUMBERT GUY
LIKE ASKING. WELL. BOOK BY.
TENS OF. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
LEAVE THAT ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
NOW WE ARE GOING TO TAKE THE
BILLS UP ACTUALLY IN A LITTLE
BIT OUT OF ORDER WELL FOR THIS
FIRST START WITH A FINAL ITEM
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOSE
THREE OF US WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YOU CAN. PRESENT YOUR
BILL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER REQUESTS
GO RIGHT AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN
YOU HEAR IT OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
THOROUGH EVALUATION OF THIS
BILL. AB EIGHT ELEVEN SIX TO
STREAMLINE THE LA COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY'S PROJECT DELIVERY AS
LOS ANGELES PREPARES FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT OLYMPIC AND
PARALYMPIC GAMES THE MEASURE
BEFORE YOU WILL BRING LA
METRO'S ENABLING STATUTES IN
ACCORD WITH ALL OTHER TRANSIT
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA. BY
REMOVING THE REQUIREMENT THAT
THE LA METRO BOARD OF DIRECTORS
APPROVED BY A TWO THIRDS VOTE
LA METRO'S ABILITY TO UTILIZE
DESIGN BUILD AS A METHOD OF
PROJECT DELIVERY. THE LA METRO
BOARD OF DIRECTORS RECENTLY
ADOPTED THE TWENTY. EIGHT BY
TWENTY EIGHT INITIATIVE THE
INITIATIVE SEEKS TO ACCELERATE
A NUMBER OF PROJECTS. TO MEET
THE TRANSPORTATION DEMANDS OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT OLYMPIC AND
PARALYMPIC GAMES. TO ENSURE
EFFICIENCY IN THE CONSTRUCTION
OF THESE PROJECTS L. A. METRO
IS AUTHORIZED TO UTILIZE DESIGN
BUILD AS A METHOD OF
PROCUREMENT. UTILIZING DESIGN
BUILD CAN REDUCE THE OVERALL
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PROJECT AND EXPEDITE PRODUCT
PROJECT DELIVERY. UNDER CURRENT
LAW THE LA METRO BOARD OF
DIRECTORS MUST APPROVE BY A TWO
THIRDS VOTE. EACH TIME LA METRO
DEEMS IT APPROPRIATE TO USE
DESIGN BUILD FOR PROJECT
CONSTRUCTION. THIS REQUIREMENT
WHICH NO OTHER TRANSIT AGENCY
IN THE STATE MUST ABIDE BY
INHIBITS LA METRO'S ABILITY TO
STAY ON TRACK FOR DELIVERING
KEY INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN
A TIMELY. AND EFFICIENT MANNER.
AT THIS TIME I WOULD LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO THE BILL'S
SPONSOR OF REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
MICHAEL TURNER. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE MISTER TURNER ON THE LINE
FROM LA METRO THAT HAS THE
SUPPORT. OF PRIMARY WITNESS.
YES WITNESS TURNING YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND I THINK HE WAS
SIMPLY MEMBER REBATES FOR OFF
THEIR OFFERING THIS MEASURE AND
TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF- FOR
WORKING WITH US AS HE SIMPLY
MEMBER MENTIONED- EIGHTY EIGHT
ELEVEN WITH CLARIFYING EXISTING
STATUTE THAT ALLOWS METRO TO
ACCELERATE PROJECT DELIVERY
USING ALTERNATIVE DELIVERY
MECHANISMS. THE STATUE WAS
CREATED IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES WHEN DESIGN BUILD
ANOTHER ALTERNATIVE DELIVERY
MECHANISMS ARE NOT AS COMMON A
DELIVERY METHOD FOR CAPITAL
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS AS THEY
HAVE SINCE BECOME. SINCE THE
STATUE WAS THE FIRST OF ITS
KIND THE LEGISLATURE INCLUDED A
TWO STEP PROCESS THAT STATUTE
REQUIRES THAT METRO FIRST
APPROVED BY A TWO THIRDS VOTE
OF FINDING THAT THE ALTERNATIVE
PROJECT DELIVERY METHOD IS
SUFFICIENT ONLY THEN CAN WE
START THE PROCUREMENT PROCESS
THE BOARD MUST APPROVE THE
SUBSEQUENT CONTRACT AWARD. IN A
SEPARATE ACTION. TO THE SUCCESS
OF THE DESIGN BUILD METHODOLOGY
PROJECT DELIVERY SUB SUBSEQUENT
DESIGN BUILD LOTS OF BEEN
PASSED THAT DO NOT REQUIRE. THE
INITIAL APPROVAL OF THE FINDING
AB ELEVEN SIMPLY ALIGNS METROS
AUTHORIZING STATUTE WITH THE
STATE'S OTHER DESIGN BUILD
STATUTES. THIS PROPOSAL BRINGS
OUR STATUTE INTO ACCORD WITH
OTHER TRANSIT AGENCIES BY
STREAMLINING THE APPROVAL
PROCESS AND WILL HELP US TO
ACCELERATE PROJECTS FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT OLYMPICS.
AGAIN I'D LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REVERSE AND
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND THE
CHAIR FOR WORKING WITH US.
THANK OU MISTER TURNER OKAY I
THINK THAT CONCLUDES THE
PRIMARY SUPPORT WITNESSED-
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANYONE
ELSE ON THE LINE AND SUPPORTIVE
AB EIGHT TO ELEVEN PLEASE. ARE
YOU WISHING TO GO TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC OR WITNESS IN
PARTICULAR. NO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC PLEASE. THANK YOU PLEASE
IN GERMANY LIKE A QUEUE UP IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH HI THANK YOU THIS IS
KEEP IT DOWN WITH THE SELF HELP
COUNTING DOWN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR I'D LIKE TO. SAY THANK
YOU TO THE OFFER FREE B.
ELEVEN. UTILIZING THAT ALLOW
LOCAL AGENCIES TO DELIVER OUR
PROJECTS IN A TIMELY MORTGAGE
MATTERS CRITICAL DESIGN BUILD
MISTER TURNER AS MENTIONED IN
THE- PRACTICE THAT WE REALIZE
YOUR MISTAKE OR SOMETIME AND-
MAYBE ELEVEN WILL GO A LONG WAY
TO HELPING TO GET READY FOR THE
OLYMPICS I JUST WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SAY WE NEED TO EMPOWER LOCAL
AGENCIES. TO DESIGN AND DELIVER
PROJECTS AS THEY SEE FIT A. B.
ELEVEN STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION SO HOW CAN THIS
COALITION IS PROUD TO SUPPORT
OUR MEMBER ONLY NATURALLY. THIS
IS YOUR THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALL PLEASE
INSERT OF A. EIGHT ELEVEN. NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM ONE NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN THAT'S TWO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TELLING ONE
THING ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES CALIFORNIA TRANSPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU MODERATOR SO
WE'LL TAKE IT TO THE GALLERY IS
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
ELEVEN. C. NINE WILL GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE ANYBODY IN SUPPORT.
OF EIGHTY EIGHT ELEVEN C. NINE.
THANK YOU THREE SO NOW THAT
WE'VE CONCLUDED SUPPORT WILL GO
ON TO OPPOSITION THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
MODERATOR DO HAVE ANYONE ON THE
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT
ELEVEN. WE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF BABY ELEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE MIN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND THERE IS NO ONE
QUEUING UP IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT
ELEVEN C. NINE. ROOM ONE TWELVE
OPPOSITION TO EIGHT ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE. OKAY WE'VE
CONCLUDED BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WE'LL TAKE IT BACK
TO MEMBER SENATOR DELHI MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU CENTER TO
LET US YES I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
COMPLEMENT THE- THE FORESIGHT
THEY WERE ABLE TO SEE SO FAR
AHEAD LOS ANGELES COUNTY WITH
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THE- BUSES
AND EVERYTHING ELSE. AND THE
VETTING PROCESS THAT THE
PROFESSIONAL STAFF. WILL HAVE
THE BOARD AND SO ON AND I FEEL
VERY COMFORTABLE THAT THIS WILL
MOVE THINGS ALONG AND I
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH THAT WITH
THE BILL. AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING. THANK YOU SENATOR
ARCHULETA SO THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR DOLLY AND I
ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REQUESTS FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE. CALL THE ROLL MOVED BY
SENATOR DELHI. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. SENATORS GONZALEZ. HI IN
DALLAS HI BATES. BATES HI ALAN.
SUCH A LETTER ARCHULETA HI
BECKER. HI CORTESE CORTESE I.
DALI DALI HI DOT. GOD HI WHERE.
MELINDA'S. WELL IT IS A MOMENT
AS I. MAN MAN I NEWMAN NEWMAN I
WILL. YEAH HI SKINNER. NUMBER
NUMBER HI BUT CASKET BY CASKEY
HIGH WILL. THIRTEEN GOT
THIRTEEN VOTES IT LOOKS LIKE IT
HAS ENOUGH TO GET OUT BUT WE'LL
PUT THE BARBELL ON CALL THANK
YOU SIMPLY MEMBER THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT OUR NEXT BILL AND I
SEE IT BELIEVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM IN THE BACK THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. THAT IS FILE ITEM
FOR EIGHTY NINE SEVENTEEN.
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU MAY
GO AHEAD AND PRESENT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SENATORS-
GOOD MORNING A. B. NINE
SEVENTEEN WILL ALLOW TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO. CAPTURE IMAGES OF
VEHICLES VIOLATING TRANSIT ONLY
LANES AND BLOCKING BUS STOPS.
DESPITE CLEAR MARKINGS AND
SIGNAGE TRANSIT ONLY LANES ARE
FREQUENTLY IGNORED THE FOR
EXAMPLE FIELD OBSERVATIONS OF
WILSHIRE BOULEVARD IN WEST LOS
ANGELES IN MY DISTRICT. FOUND
ONE VIOLATION EVERY FOUR
MINUTES. BUS ONLY LANE
VIOLATIONS AND PARKED VEHICLES
CAUSE DELAYS AND POSE SAFETY
ISSUES TO RIDERS. TRANSIT
OPERATORS ARE FORCED TO
MANEUVER AROUND CONGESTED LANES
AND MAKE DROP OFFS FURTHER FROM
THE CURB. CAMERA ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED
IN SAN FRANCISCO ALAMEDA CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY AND CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY TO DETER DRIVERS FROM
IMPEDING. RELIABLE SERVICE.
FORWARD FACING CAMERAS ARE
ATTACHED TO THE BUSES AND ONLY
RECORD LICENSE PLATES OF
VEHICLES THAT ARE BLOCKING BUS
LANES IMAGES ARE THEN SENT TO
LOCAL ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO
REVIEW AND ISSUE A CITATION.
THESE CAMERON FORSMAN PROGRAMS
HELP TO REDUCE VIOLATIONS AND
IMPROVED TRAVEL TIMES AND
ADJUST OUR PILOT PHASE IN SAN
FRANCISCO THEY SHOWED A 20%
REDUCTION IN DELAYS. AND EVEN
FEWER REPEAT CITATIONS IN
ALAMEDA AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
AC TRANSIT SAW A 21%
IMPROVEMENT IN ON TIME
PERFORMANCE. AMARIN FORSMAN
WORKS IT IS COST EFFECTIVE AND
IDEAL FOR BUSY STREETS WHERE
PARKING ENFORCEMENT IS SIMPLY
NOT REALISTIC. EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTEEN WILL PROVIDE RIDERS
WITH ACCESS TO SAFE AND RAPID
BUS SERVICE AND ENSURE PUBLIC
TRANSIT REMAINS COMPETITIVE IN
ATTRACTING MORE RIDERS. LASTLY
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THE AMENDMENTS WHICH
WE ARE ADOPTING IN THIS
COMMITTEE. I APPRECIATE YOU AND
YOUR STAFF WILLINGNESS TO
ENGAGE WITH US ON THIS ISSUE
AND I'M GLAD WE WERE ABLE TO
FIND A MIDDLE GROUND TO
STRENGTHEN THE BILL. WITH ME
TESTIFYING TODAY IN SUPPORT OR
MICHAEL TURNER DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
AT ALL IN METRO AND STEPHEN
JONES EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
REPRESENTATIVE AT AC TRANSIT
THANK YOU SEVEN MEMBER AND I
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY- THAT
YOU WOULD BE TAKING AND
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS WHICH
JUST ADDS A MINOR REPORTING
LANGUAGE- REQUIREMENT TO
INCLUDE TRAFFIC SAFETY
OUTCOMES. AND REQUIRES A
PARTICIPATING CITIES TO HAVE
PAYMENT OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE VERY LOW INCOME THAT IS
CORRECT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALL RIGHT SO
WE'LL GO TO THE LINE SUPPORT
LINE- MISTER TURNER FROM LA
METRO WE BELIEVE HE IS ON THE
LINE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF.
EIGHTY NINE ONE SEVEN. THANK
YOU MADAMCHAIR SYNDICATE
MEMBERS WITH US MICHAEL TURNER
FOR ON BEHALF OF THE LA COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. AND AGAIN THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US.
AS A FAMILY MEMBER OR MENTION
THE B. NINE ONE SEVEN WITH
AUTHORIZED PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO INSTALL A FORWARD
FACING CAMERAS. IN OUR TRANSIT
VEHICLES TO ASSIST WITH
ENFORCEMENT OF PARKING
VIOLATIONS IN TRANSIT ONLY
LANES AND AT BUS STOPS. IN LA
COUNTY 66% OF BUS RIDERS
IDENTIFIED FORTINO 15% IDENTIFY
AS AFRICAN AFRICAN AMERICAN.
THE MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME OF
METRO'S BUS RIDERS IS LESS THAN
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR. THE ABILITY OF THOUSANDS
OF THESE WRITERS IS BEING
DELAYED BY PEOPLE WHO PARK
ILLEGALLY IN BUS ONLY LANES.
FOR A SINGLE CAR THAT IS
ILLEGALLY PARKED IN THE BUS
LANE UP TO EIGHTY BUCKS WRITERS
ARE DELAYED EACH MINUTE. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND
RIDERS DELAYED IN AN HOUR IF IT
TAKES ON FORCED IN AN HOUR. TO
CLEAR THE LANE FOR SERVICE.
WITH THIS ADORING METRONET THE
TRANSIT AGENCIES CAN PARTNER
WITH LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT
ALREADY HAVE PARKING
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY. METRO
WOULD NOT BE ISSUING PARKING
CITATIONS UNDER THIS PROGRAM IN
CITIES FOR THE EXISTING
AUTHORITY. WOULD ENFORCE
PARKING ON THEIR STREET. E.
NINETY EIGHTY NINE ONE SEVEN
SIMPLY CREATES AN ADDED TOOL TO
ASSIST IN THIS EFFORT TO KEEP
UP FLAMES CLEAR. PONDERING
EIGHTY NINE ONE SEVEN TO
AUTHORIZE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
TRANSIT LANE FOR SPRINT PROGRAM
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES. CITY OF LOS
ANGELES A FEMALE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND OTHER CITIES IN LA
COUNTY WHERE BUS LANES OPERATE
AND WILLING AND WILL OPERATE IN
THE FUTURE. CURRENTLY WE
OPERATE BUSES ON OVER TWENTY
NINE MILES OF TRANSIT ONLY
LANES WHICH ARE EXCLUSIVE TO
BUS OPERATION DURING POSTED
HOURS. THIS PROVIDES RAPID BUS
SERVICE TO THE TEN MILLION
RESIDENTS OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
METRO EXPANDED THE NETWORK OF
TRANSIT ONLY LANES FROM TWENTY
NINE MILES TO OVER ONE HUNDRED
MILES OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
IMPROVING THE SPEED RELIABILITY
AND RELIABILITY OF OUR BUS
NETWORK THROUGH AT NINE ONE
SEVEN. CENTRAL TO MOVING MORE
PEOPLE IT'S ALSO ESSENTIAL TO
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO RETURN TO
TRANSIT. OBVIOUSLY TRANSIT HAS
FACED CHALLENGES IN- WITH THE
PANDEMIC BUT WHAT WE HAVE HEARD
FROM OUR CUSTOMERS IS THAT.
IMPROVING OUR TRANSIT SERVICE
IMPROVING THE EFFICIENCY AND
SAFETY OF IT. IS ALSO IMPORTANT
TO GETTING OUR WRITERS BACK.
SHOULD ALSO MENTION THAT PARKED
ILLEGALLY PARKED CARS AND BUS
ONLY LANES IS A SAFETY HAZARD.
WHAT A CAR IS PARKED IN A BUS
ONLY LANE. THE BUS EITHER HAS
TO WAIT TO MOVE OR IT HAS TO
SWERVE. OUT INTO TRAFFIC LANES
TO GET AROUND A PARKED CAR. AND
THAT IS A SAFETY HAZARD. WE'VE
BEEN STUDYING HOW TO IMPROVE
TRANSIT PERFORMANCE IN THE
LANES AND WE HAVE FOUND THAT
PARKING. IS ONE OF THE KEY
IMPEDIMENTS TO IMPROVING
TRANSIT SERVICE. THIS BILL WILL
HELP US TO RESOLVE THEIR
PROBLEMS AND IMPROVE TRANSIT
SERVICE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND
I'D LIKE TO THINK IT'S SIMPLY
MEMBER BLOOM FOR AUTHORING THE
BILL. I THINK THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU MISTER
TURNER AND I BELIEVE THERE IS A
SECOND WITNESS- PRIMARY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT WHICH IS MISTER
STEVE JONES FROM AC TRANSIT ON
THE COASTLINE AS WELL MODERATOR
PLEASE. WITNESS JONES YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU- GOOD
MORNING STEVEN JOE AC TRANSIT
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS REPRESENTATIVE
URGING THE COMMUNITY SUPPORT
FOR EIGHTY NINE SEVENTEEN.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS RELY ON
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION TO
CONNECT THEM TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. BUT TRANSIT
SYSTEMS CAN'T PROVIDE A SAFE
AND RELIABLE SERVICE WHEN
MOTORISTS ILLEGALLY PARK THEIR
CARS IN TRANSIT ONLY LANES OR
TRANSIT STOPS. ILLEGAL PARKING
MAKES PUBLIC TRANSIT LESS
RELIABLE LESS SAY AND LESS
ACCEPTABLE BUT IN AT RISK THE
LIVES AND LIVELIHOODS OF
MILLIONS OF LOW INCOME AND
VULNERABLE BECAUSE CALIFORNIA.
ABC TRANSIT 65% OF OUR RIDERS
ARE LOW INCOME. 75% OF PEOPLE
OF COLOR NEARLY HALF OF OUR
WRITERS DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO A
WORKING VEHICLE. MANY TRANSIT
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
SIMILAR RIGHT OF PROFILES.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS AC TRANSIT
USE CAMERAS TO DISCOURAGE
ILLEGAL PARKING IN THE TRANSIT
ONLY LANES OF OUR NEW BUS RAPID
TRANSIT SYSTEM. ON AVERAGE WE
ISSUE ABOUT THREE POINT FIVE
TICKETS PER DAY ON A LINE THAT
CARRIES SEVEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED RIDERS PER DAY AND IS
PROJECTED TO SOON CARRY AS MANY
AS ELEVEN THOUSAND RIDERS PER
DAY. THE CAMERAS ARE HELPING TO
DISCOURAGE ILLEGAL PARKING OUR
SERVICES ON TIME PERFORMANCE IS
EXCEEDING EIGHTY PERCENT.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE NOW WRITER
SERVICE WITH THE CONFIDENCE
THAT WE WILL DELIVER THEM
SAFELY AND ON TIME THE JOBS IN
THE SCHOOLS COMMUNITY CENTERS
AND MORE ALSO WE RECEIVED ZERO
PRIVACY COMPLAINTS. I URGE YOU
TO EXPAND CURRENT LAW SO THAT
CAMERAS CAN BE USED TO DETER
ILLEGAL PARKING AT BUS STOPS.
IN ADDITION TO TRANSIT ONLY
NINE. IT SO WILL PROVIDE SAFER
MORE RELIABLE AND MORE
EQUITABLE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. ESPECIALLY TO
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHO
RELY ON PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION GREAT THANK YOU
MISTER JOHNSON I WILL TAKE IT
TO THE GALLERY IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN SUPPORTIVE AB NINE
ONE SEVEN WE DO HAVE SOMEONE
THAT I COULD MORNING STEVE
WELCOME HAVE THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
THE L. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION REPORTED
TRANSPORTATION AND SO FORTH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN US SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY OF
AB NINE ONE SEVEN. SEE NONE
THANK YOU SIR. I WILL GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYONE AND
HEALTH AND SUPPORT SEE NONE.
THE MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT BACK
TO THE QUOTE THAT TO THE
CONFERENCE LINE FOR ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE ONE
SEVEN. IF YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. NINE ONE
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL BEGIN
WITH A LINE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
THAT'S TWO FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL
CALIFORNIA TRANSISTORS EACH ONE
A CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL I JUST
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT ECHO THAT
BANK THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
EXPRESSED YOU. THAT INSURANCE
COMMITTEE STAFF ARE WORKING
WITH OUR SERVICE STATION AND
THE CO SPONSOR. OF THIS BILL-
TO MOVE AMENDMENTS SCORED JUST
ONE ENCOURAGER EITHER TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT A COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF.
EIGHTY NINE ONE SEVEN. WELL NOT
A LINE NUMBER THIRTY ONE AT
THREE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SO HE ACTUALLY SHOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA STRONG. YEAH. THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT TIME
IT WILL COME FROM LINE NUMBER
TWENTY SIX THAT'S TWO SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JOSH SHAW WITH SHAW
YOUR INTUITION ELTERN LAND FOR
THE SAN MATEO COUNTY TRANSIT
DISTRICT AS WELL AS THE SAN
FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. OPEN
SUPPORT MAY ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS FOR
WORKING WITH US ON TODAY'S
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT COMIC COME
SOMEONE NUMBER FORTY THREE
THAT'S FOUR THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THAT'S NOT INSURANCE
SANDERS MATTHEW FIVE RULING ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
PARKING AT THE- PORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
SIX COMING FROM SOMEONE NUMBER
FORTY EIGHT THAT'S FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF STAND
THERE BY CHANCE STATION THIRTY
FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. COMING FROM SOMEONE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE THAT'S TWO
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS INJURY ACTUALLY
ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI ADDING- MAYOR
CITIES THANKS TO FAMILY MEMBER
BLOOM FOR CARRYING THE SUPPORT
MANAGER- FOR MORE THAN ONCE AND
FOR US. AND OUR OTHER CO
SPONSORS AND ALSO WE WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE CONSULTING
THE CHIR- LOOKING TOWARDS A
SOLUTION ON THIS PROPOSAL
NATURAL. THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. MICROSOFT LINE NUMBER
THIRTY THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS MICHAEL
SHERIDAN STREETS FROM MENTAL-
PRIVATE CARS OFTEN USE BUT SOME
REMAIN WITH THEIR OWN PERSONAL
EXPRESS LANES HERE IN LOS
ANGELES IN THE SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH TRAFFIC OFFICERS TO BE
OPENED FOR SPONSORING MANUALLY
YES I'M SURE WE WANT WE CAN.
STOP THIS BILL WOULD HELP BUT
THE P. BOXES KEYPAD BY TWENTY
FOUR BUT THE ONLY AND URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME WE'RE JUST TAKING
NAME AN ORGANIZATION- IN
SUPPORT. OF A. B. NINE ONE
SEVEN PLEASE NEXT COMMENT. NEXT
COMING TO SOMEONE NUMBER FORTY
THAT'S FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BALKANS
OFFICE ON BEHALF OF LONG BEACH
TRANSIT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
SIX COMMENT IS FROM ONE NUMBER
THIRTY FOUR THAT'S THREE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE THIRTY
FOUR YOU MIGHT HAVE YOURSELF
SELF MUTED CAN YOU CHECK YOUR
LINE FOR MUTE. SO I WAS REALLY
THIS IS DANNY GALBRAITH ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ADVOCATES. STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. I'M SURE THIS TIME
WE'VE EXHAUSTED ALL SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WE THAT CONCLUDES
OUR WITNESSES AND TESTIMONY AND
SUPPORTS WILL MOVE OVER TO
OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
J. BIEBER FROM SAFER STREETS LA
CO HOST ON THE COASTLINE
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE ENSURE
HE'S ON THE LINE. CHECKING FOR
YOU ONE MOMENT PLANS. I DO
APOLOGIZE WHAT WAS THE LAST
THING WE'RE LOOKING FOR DOESN'T
MATCH WHAT'S ON MY AGENDA J.
BIEBER SAFER STREETS LA. I DO
NOT SHOW THAT THE WITNESS IN
THE QUEUE AT THE START TIME IN
LINE I AM ONLINE HELLO. THERE
HERE IS. OKAY MISTER BEAVER P.
LIKE TO GO RIGHT AHEAD- IN
OPPOSITION TO AB NINE ONE SEVEN
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN WITH GETTING MY NAME'S
J. PIEPER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
TAPE IF YOU TELL A RESEARCH AND
PUBLIC POLICY ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING THE INTERESTS OF
THE TWENTY SEVEN MILLION LIKE
THE START BUTTON STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WELL EVERYONE
AGREED THAT APPLICATION PUBLIC
TRANSIT IS IN EFFECT TO BE
ENACTED EIGHTY NINE SEVENTEEN
WOULD RESULT IN MASSIVELY
PICKETING IS ULTIMATELY GETTING
AN ECONOMIC HARDSHIP ESPECIALLY
FOR THE LOW INCOME AND MINORITY
COMMUNITIES. FOR EXAMPLE THERE
OVER THIRTEEN THOUSAND LAPTOPS
WITH INTEL INVESTORS SERVICE
ITSELF. CAN YOU JUST ONE
VIOLATION PREDATED STOCK IT'S
pALMOST FIVE MILLION TICKETS
WOULD BE ISSUED EACH YEAR THIS
TRANSLATES TO OVER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS TO FIND ANNUALLY. JUST
THE TELLING A CONSERVATIVE. THE
CATTLE PEOPLE. IN A BUCKET
LOADING DON'T BE A HI WE
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS. EXPANDING
THE USE OF. THE POPULATION WILL
ACT THE- INCREASE ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP HELLO CAN BUT I DIDN'T
HAVE TO PAY. MANY ARE
STRUGGLING TO RECOVER FROM THE
FACT THAT THE PANDEMIC NOW ON
THE VERGE OF LOSING THEIR
HOUSING KIND OF THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS TICKET FOR
MOMENTARILY STOPPING IT BUT
DOWN. THE COURSE THEN A FAMILY
DOCTOR AT ST. ADDITIONALLY THE
VEHICLE REGISTRATION CANNOT BE
REMOVED IF THERE IS NOT ANY
PARKING SPOT AS A RESULT OF
RECEIVING IT ONE OF THE TICKET
THE VEHICLE OWNER AND OUR
ENTIRE FAMILY MIGHT. BE USED AS
THE PRIMARY VEHICLE POTENTIALLY
THEIR APPOINTMENT MEETING UP TO
DEALING WITH PAIN LEADING TO
DEEPENING TOPIC. FURTHER DETAIL
PROVIDE LITTLE TO NO PROTECTION
AGAINST THE LATEST DECLINING A
PALLET FORK ON THE PROPERTY
AFTER I PRIMARILY TICKETING FOR
MINOR VIOLATIONS THANK YOU. A
NECESSARY A MOMENTARILY
STOPPING A TRANSIT LANES WERE
BLOCKED OFF. OR THERE ANY
RESTRICTIONS ON THE MAGNITUDE.
OF THE FIGHT IF YOU LOOK BACK
ON. THE TWENTY FIFTEEN AT TEN
WITH DOCTOR YOU TOO CAN. COME
TALK TO THE COURT. BY THAT. CAN
ONLY. HOWEVER THE- BACK DELETED
ONLY CONTAINS. TWO MONTHLY DATA.
AT THE HEIGHT OF THE- FAR TOO
LITTLE PROVIDE ANY. INFORMATION
ABOUT. EFFECT AND IMPORTANT THE
AETNA IMPACT OF THE TICKET. YOU
CAN RESPECT REQUESTS AND- ON
THE- LET THE AMENDED CONFLICT
THAT THE- THAT DATABASE KIND OF
CONFRONTATION. NE ADDITIONAL
YEAR REQUIRED TO REPORT BACK TO
THE- YOU CAN. THE LINK ALL YOU
WORK DATA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR- SO WILL NOW GO AHEAD TO THE
GALLERY FOR ANY ONE WHO'D LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO. AB
NINE ONE SEVEN C. NINE. ANYONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
OPPOSITION DEMANDS A MODERATOR
WILL TAKE IT BACK TO THE
CONFERENCE LINE ANYONE WHO'D
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO AB NINE ONE SEVEN PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE WITNESSED
KRAMER MATTER IS ON THE DOCKET
SHE WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THE TIME. MY
APOLOGIES YES WE HAVE BIG
EXPECTED CRAMER MOTOR FROM THE
ACLU MY APOLOGIES GO RIGHT
AHEAD- MISS KRAMER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR NO WORRY FACTOR
KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
ACLU'S CALIFORNIA ACTION ALSO
IN OPPOSITION. EIGHTY NINE
SEVEN SIX TO DECREASE
CONSTRUCTIONS AND HAND THE ONLY
LANES AND MAKE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SAFER AND MORE
EFFICIENT. BY RELYING ON THE
FOLK NATION AND THAT INCREASED
SURVEILLANCE OF THE COLLISION.
CALIFORNIANS ARE INCREASINGLY
CONCERNED THAT BIG TAX
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND THE
POLICE HAVE COLLABORATED TO
CREATE AND BACK SURVEILLANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT STOCK OUR
PERSONAL INFORMATION.
GENERALIZATION AND PERMISSION
FOR THEIR OWN PROFIT AND POWER.
DESPITE A LITTLE GOOD
INTENTIONS TO HELP PREVENT
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE AND
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. EIGHTY
NINE ON SEVEN GOES TOO FAR BY
FOSTERING THE USE OF
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY.
SERVICE FOUNDED AND FUNDED AT
THE EXPENSE OF THE REST OF
THAT. THANKS FOR READING THE
NEWSPAPER ROUND NOWADAYS LIKE
LPR. CAMERAS ON PUBLIC BUSES.
EIGHTY NINE ONE SEVEN RELIES ON
THE FALSE NOTION THAT
SURVEILLANCE BENEFITS. THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE SURVEILLED.
BUT MIKE HAMMER. OFFERS TALE TO
THE IDEA THAT. COLLISION WHAT
I'M FORESEEING COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES MIGHT EIGHTY NINE
ONE THOUSAND SURVEILLANCE
SYSTEM BECAUSE IN ADDITION TO
THE CRIPPLING FINANCIAL BURDEN
FOR CALIFORNIA DRIVERS UNABLE
TO PAY THE COST OF THE TICKET.
EIGHTY NINE NINE SEVEN GOAL OF
MAKING PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
MORE EFFICIENT IS IMPORTANT BUT
PREVAILING. I'M NOT AFFILIATION.
THERE ARE MORE EFFECTIVE WAYS
OF ACHIEVING CLEAR TRANSIT ONLY
LANES. AND JACK HEARD- MEDIANTE
PREVENT CARS FROM PARKING
ILLEGALLY THEY CAN ALSO ADD
MORE SIGNS THAT CLEARLY
INDICATE. WHEN AND WHERE MOTOR
PARK. MANY BEGINS AT THOSE
METHODS INSTEAD OF TE PROGRAM
TECHNOLOGIES AND EIGHTY NINE
AND- THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY THAT CONCLUDES OUR
PRIMARY WITNESSES OPPOSITION
AND WE'LL GO BACK TO THE-
MODERATOR IF THERE ARE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES WE WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
NINE ONE SEVEN. AS A REMINDER
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK OUT IN
OPPOSITION OF BABY NINE ONE
SEVEN YOU MADE PRESS ONE THEN
IF ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE QUEUEING UP
PLEASE JUST ALLOW A MOMENT
FIRST BRIGHTLINE NUMBERS. WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
THAT'S TOO FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
HARDLY READ AND I'M CALLING
FROM THE LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA WE URGE YOU
TO OPPOSE EIGHTY NINE SEVENTEEN
AS USUAL THE DISPROPORTIONATELY
NEGATIVE IMPACT THAT THE BILL
WILL HAVE ON COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE ONE MORE TO PLACE IN
THE QUEUE HERE IT'S LINE NUMBER
FORTY TWO THAT'S FOUR TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MORNING MADAM
CHAIR ANDERSON MICHAEL NOCERA
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
NINE ONE SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. AND
THERE IS NO MORE IN Q.
PROPOSITION EIGHTY NINE ONE
SEVEN OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR
SO WE'LL TAKE IT BACK BUT- TWO
MEMBERS I BELIEVE WE'VE ALREADY
GONE TO THE GALLERY IN THE
ROOM- ONE TWELVE AS WELL- BUT
I'LL START OFF BY SAYING THANK
YOU SO MUCH VERY VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM I KNOW- WE
WENT BACK AND FORTH ON A FEW
DIFFERENT AMENDMENTS AND WE
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BEING AMENABLE TO THOSE- BUT AS
IT STATES NOW WHAT I THINK IS
MOST IMPORTANT IS ENSURING THAT
THERE WAS AN EQUITY COMPONENT
TO LOWERING FINES AND ALLOWING
CITIES TO. ENABLE A PAYMENT
PLAN AND ESPECIALLY FOR-
DISCRETION FOR THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY OR FOR THE
PARKING ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO
PROVIDE- OR ME. TO ALLOW THEM
TO- NOT PROVIDE A TICKET IF
NEED BE IF THESE IF THEY FIND
SOMEBODY MAYBE SLEEPING IN
THEIR CAR OR WHAT HAVE YOU- IN
ADDITION WE'VE INCLUDED IN THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENT THE
TRAFFIC SAFETY OUTCOMES THIS IS
ACTUALLY IMPROVE CONGESTION
THIS IS ACTUALLY COMBINED PROVE
TRAFFIC SAFETY. UNDER THAT YOU
KNOW ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW ALLOW
CITIES TO CREATE DIFFERENT-
STREETSCAPES BASED ON THIS
INFORMATION AND OUTCOMES THAT
YOU PROVIDED SO WITH THAT IN
WITH MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT
TRANSIT HAS BROUGHT UP
ESPECIALLY WITH RIDERSHIP DOWN
I DO BELIEVE THAT WE'VE GOT A
WE'RE IN A GOOD PLACE HERE SO I
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT- SO WITH THAT I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU VENTURE WE HAVE A NEW
SEATING ARRANGEMENTS I'M TRYING
A NEW APPROACH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM IS GETS- I DIED I'M GLAD
TO SUPPORT THE BILL- I AM-
AWARE AND SENSITIVE TO THE
PRIVACY ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED BUT I MY PERSONAL BELIEF
IS THIS IS A GOOD USE. OF
CAMERA TECHNOLOGY THIS IS A GUY
THAT SHOULD BE A GOOD AND
EFFECTIVE DETERRENT. AND WHEN
THE TIME TO PROVIDE LOVE B.
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR OF
POSSIBLE SAID THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
US SENATOR MAN. ONE ECHO MY-
THE COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE
FROM OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FULLERTON. HI HI BOB YOU SEE WE
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT EQUITY AND
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT BUT-
THE UNDERLYING POLICY HERE IS
FUNDAMENTALLY A GOOD ONE WHICH
AS WE ALL STATE IS ALSO
EQUITABLE TO PROVIDE MASS
TRANSIT TO PEOPLE WHO NEED TO
GET TO WORK WHO MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO FOR THEIR OWN CAR. AND WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT EQUITY OVER THE
LONG RUN BUT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO GET OUR CLIMATE CRISIS
UNDER CONTROL AND GETTING MORE
PEOPLE INTO VEHICLES OF MASS
TRANSIT HAS TO BE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE START STEERING
PEOPLE TOWARDS. AND I THINK
THIS IS FINALLY GOOD POLICY AND
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR AT THE EARLIEST
POSSIBLE OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND SENATOR
MCCASKEY. MAN SURE APPRECIATE
IT CLARIFICATIONS OF THE-
AMENDMENTS ON THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT AS WELL AS THE
IMPACT ON- DISADVANTAGE OF.
POPULATION I AM. AND I THINK. A
LOT OF THE OBJECTIONS THAT WE
HEARD FROM THAT AT LEAST PEOPLE
THAT REPORTED. WHAT WE SHOULD
BE ADDRESSING THAT AMENDMENT-
HI AS I SAID ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE I KNOW THAT THIS
MEASURE IF IT IS APPROVED HERE
WILL GO THERE AND I THINK THE
OBJECTIONS THAT WERE RAISED
ABOUT SURVEILLANCE AND THE
SCOPE OF THE- THE CAMERA USE
ARE MORE APPROPRIATE FOR THAT
FROM THE TEN- THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. WITH
THAT SAID I BELIEVE I HEARD
WHEN THE WITNESSES TALK ABOUT
THE HAVING THE CAMERA ON THE ON
THE VEHICLE WILL SPEED UP. THE
TRAFFIC BECAUSE WE'LL BE ABLE
TO SEE THE PARK VEHICLE THAT'S
IN THE- IT'S IN THE- BUS ONLY
LANE. SO I'M WONDERING FOR A
SOON RIGHT NOW THERE THE- TREND
THE BUS TRUCK DRIVER WHOEVER
TRANSIT OPERATOR. SEES SOMEBODY
THAT'S PARKED THERE SEE XTC
CARD IT'S A BAND OR A REAL REAL
PARKING THEY WOULD CALL. THE
TOW TRUCK PEOPLE TO COME AND
GET IT AND TAKE IT OUT. SO HOW
DOES THE CAMERA. BEING SENT TO
THE TOW TRUCK PEOPLE AND SAYING
COME OVER TO THIS ADDRESS AND
PICK THIS CAR UP VERSUS THE
OPERATOR CALLING UP SPEED UP
THE FLOW OF THE BUSES I GET
YEAH IF THE IF I'M
UNDERSTANDING IT RIGHT. IT
MAYBE IT'S ONE THING TO MAKE
THE AUTHOR SOMEBODY SURE
ABSOLUTELY AND I KNOW THAT
THERE IS- ALSO. A SIXTY DAY-
SORT OF TIME FRAME AS WELL FOR
EDUCATION BEFORE A PUBLIC
EDUCATION BEFORE ANYTHING IS
ACTUALLY FORCED BUT I WILL
ALLOW- AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IF YOU'D LIKE TO ANSWER THAT
NOW OR IF YOU'D LIKE TO GO
AHEAD AND INCLUDE THAT IN YOUR
CLOTHES. I CAN INCLUDE THE
RESPONSE MY CLOTHES OKAY
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SENATOR
AKOWSKI AND I WILL DOUBLE DOWN
ON THOSE COMMENTS AS WELL AND
THAT PRIVACY CONCERNS MANY OF
US ON THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
WE ALSO HAVE THE CHAIR
JUDICIARY IN THIS COMMITTEE.
AND CERTAINLY THOSE ARE MOST
APPROPRIATE FOR THAT COMMITTEE
SENATOR MELINDA. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I JUST- I. I FEEL
IN ORDER TO MAKE. YOU KNOW AN
INTELLIGENT AND INFORMED
DECISION ON THIS BILL THAT THE
QUESTION THAT WAS POSED TO THE
AUTHOR IT PROBABLY NEEDS TO BE
ANSWERED PRIOR TO HIS CLOTHES
BECAUSE IT MAY. WARRANT SOME
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS SO IT'S
HARDER TO YOU KNOW IF IT'S JUST
IN THE CLOTHES WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE MUCH TIME TO RUMINATE OVER
IT SO I WOULD JUST ASK IF WE
COULD HAVE THE AUTHOR ADDRESS
THAT NOW AND THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL SURE ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO DO THAT THANK YOU AND A
POINT WELL TAKEN- THE IDEA HERE
IS TO BEGIN ENFORCING SO THAT
PEOPLE WILL STOP- PULLING OVER
IN THE CURB LANE. WHAT WE'RE
SEEING NOW IS AMAZON TRUCKS
TNCS AND WE WILL SEE IT-
OUTSIDE OF THE BUS LANES THAT
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME WELL. WHEN
IT HAPPENS IN THE BUSTLING.
IT'S A REAL PROBLEM FOR BUS
TRANSIT. BUT THE IDEA IS NOT
TO- MOVE THAT CAR IMMEDIATELY
IT'S TO BEGIN AN ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM. THAT SENDS A MESSAGE-
THAT'S CLEARLY UNDERSTOOD. THAT
YOU'LL RECEIVE A TICKET IF- OR
THERE'S A HIGH LIKELIHOOD THAT
YOU'LL RECEIVE A TICKET- IN THE
IN THAT SITUATION. AND THAT
WILL OVER TIME AS WE HEARD FROM
BOTH WITNESSES. REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF. VIOLATORS THAT EXIST
ON THE STREET. TANK YOU SEMI
MEMBER. DID ANYONE ELSE HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS RELATED TO
THAT QUESTION OR ANY OTHER
GENERAL QUESTIONS. OKAY C. NINE
THANK YOU MEMBERS- SO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE-
YOU MAY DO SO RIGHT NOW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR WORKING WITH US
AND TO YOUR SUPPORTERS AS WELL-
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON EIGHTY
NINE ONE SEVEN PLEASE SENATOR
MINT THANK YOU MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
SENATORS GONZALEZ HI. AS WELL
AS I. ST STILL ALAN. SUCH A
LETTER PARKLAND HIGH BECKER.
CORTESE CORTESE HI DOLLY ALI
NOW DOT. THE HI WHERE.
BELINDA'S I'M SORRY. LET US
KNOW. MAN MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN
HI RUBIO. RUBIO HI SKINNER.
HUMBERT NUMBER I LIKE HEALTHY
WHAT KASKY HIGH WILL. NINE
THREE OKAY NINE THREE THAT
APPEARS TO HAVE ENOUGH TO GET
OUT DOESN'T REMEMBER LUKE THANK
YOU BUT WE'LL KEEP THAT BILL ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT NEXT BILL WILL
BE GOING BACK UP THE FILE FILE
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE. EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNER HOT
BREATH. THE SEVEN MEMBER THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS FIRST
OF ALL I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPTTHE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY THAT A BICYCLE MUST
FEEL TO A VEHICLE STOPPED AT AN
INTERSECTION AND YIELD TO
PEDESTRIANS IN AN INTERSECTION
AS NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
YOUR CONSULTANT FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF ON THIS BILL HER
HELP IS MUCH APPRECIATED EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND MAKE
INTERSECTIONS SAFER FOR BIKE
RIDERS DRIVERS AND PEDESTRIANS
BY ALLOWING BIKE RIDERS TO
TREAT STOP SIGNS AS YIELD
SIGNS. WHEN APPROACHING AN
INTERSECTION WHILE THIS MAY
SEEM COUNTERINTUITIVE YIELDING
IS ALREADY OF ALL VEHICLE TO
ONE EIGHT OH FOUR ALREADY
PROVIDES A CLEAR LEGAL
DEFINITION AND EXPECTATION FOR
THOSE REQUIRED TO YIELD AT
INTERSECTIONS. UNDER THIS CODE
SECTION THE DRIVER OF ANY
VEHICLE INCLUDING BIKES
APPROACHING AN INTERSECTION
WITH A YIELD SIGN MUST YIELD TO
THE RIGHT OF WAY TO ANY
VEHICLES AND PEDESTRIANS WHO
HAVE ENTERED THE INTERSECTION.
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY TWO USES OF
COMMON UNDERSTANDING OF YOUR
DESIGN HELLO BIKE RIDERS
APPROACHING AN INTERSECTION
WITH A STOP SIGN TO SLOW DOWN
AND YIELD TO ANY CARS AND
PEDESTRIANS. ALREADY IN THE
INTERSECTION. IF IT IS A TO DO
SO AND ONLY FOR SAFE TO DO SO
BY SCHOOLS CAN THEN PROCEED.
THROUGH THE INTERSECTION
WITHOUT HAVING TO JUMP OFF
THEIR BIKES PUT THEIR FEET ON
THE GROUND AND MAKE A FULL AND
COMPLETE STOP. FOR BIKE RIDERS
THIS PROCESS IS INTUITIVE
BECAUSE IT FITS WITH THE
EVERYDAY RIDING EXPERIENCE.
THEY KNOW THEY ARE THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN THE INTERSECTION
BUT FOR DRIVERS THIS CONCEPT
MAY BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE. SO HERE'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING. THERE TO GENERAL
STRATEGIES FOR BIKE RIDERS LIKE
MYSELF TO REDUCE RISKS AT
INTERSECTIONS. ONE TO INCREASE
OUR VISIBILITY TO DRIVERS AND
TO REDUCE OUR EXPOSURE BY
SHORTENING THE PERIOD OF TIME.
WE REMAIN AND WITHIN THE
INTERSECTION. YIELDING ENABLES
BROKERS TO DO BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS. BY ALLOWING BIKE RIDERS
TO RETAIN A MODEST AMOUNT OF
FOR MOMENTUM THEY ARE MORE
VISIBLE VISIBLE. TO WRITERS THE
INVISIBLE TO CARS. HUMAN
PERCEPTION BUT EVOLUTIONARILY
OPTIMIZED TO BE MORE SENSITIVE
TO MOVING AND STATIONARY
OBJECTS AND IT'S ALSO EASIER.
FOR DRIVERS TO SEE THINGS
BETTER FOR THEM THAN ON THEIR
SIDE. BIKE RIDERS ALSO REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF TOTAL TIME
THEY'RE EXPOSED TO THE INTERNET
TO A POSSIBLE CRASH. WITH
VEHICLES BY ENTERING AND
EXITING INTERSECTIONS MORE
QUICKLY THAN IF THEY HAVE TO
MAKE A FULL COMPLETE STOP AND
THEN RESTART UP THEIR MOMENTUM.
DELAWARE ADOPTED A STOP AS
YIELDS FOR BLOCK FOR BICYCLISTS
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN. ACCORDING
TO THE DELAWARE STATE POLICE
CRASHES INVOLVING BICYCLISTS
SPECIFICALLY. AT STOP SIGNS
CONTROLLED INTERSECTIONS FELL
BY 23% IN THE THIRTY MONTHS
AFTER THE GOVERNOR. SIGNED THE
BICYCLE FRIENDLY DELAWARE ACT
INTO LAW. OTHER STATES HAVE
IMPLEMENTED THE STOP IS YOUR
LEGISLATION INCLUDING IDAHO
DELAWARE UTAH COLORADO.
ARKANSAS WASHINGTON INCLUDING
SEATTLE NORTH DAKOTA AND
OREGON. WHETHER CALIFORNIANS
RIGHT FOR RECREATION AS PART OF
A SUSTAINABLE LIFESTYLE CHOICES
OR BECAUSE IT'S THE ONLY
TRANSPORTATION OPTION. EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY TWO INSURERS THAT%
BIKE RIDERS DRIVERS AND
PEDESTRIANS ARE SAFE IN
INTERSECTIONS WITH THE STOP
SIGN. EIGHTY ONE TWENTY WOULD
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL TO PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE WITH A FIFTY FOOT
REPORT. BY JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN. I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT EIGHTY ONE TWENTY
TWO IS NOT A BILL TO AUTHORIZE
BIKE RIDERS TO DO A ROLLING
STOP OR BLOW THROUGH A STOP
SIGN. THAT IS THE LEGAL NOW IT
WOULD BE ILLEGAL UNDER EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. WHAT EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY TWO SAYS IS THAT A
DRIVER A BIKE RIDER CAN HEAL
THAT INTERSECTION WITH A STOP
SIGN. JUST LIKE US DRIVERS
YIELD IN A ROUND ABOUT WE
APPROACH THE INTERSECTION WE
EVALUATE THE SITUATION WE YIELD
TO THE RIGHT AWAY TO THE
TRAFFIC ALREADY IN THE
ROUNDABOUT. WE ONLY ANOTHER
ROUND ABOUT WHEN IT'S SAFE TO
DO SO WE'RE ASKING TO DO THIS.
FOR BIKES AT INTERSECTIONS OF
BECAUSE IT MAKES US SAFER. AND
WE KNOW FROM THE DATA FROM
SEATTLE. TO DELAWARE IT MAKES A
SAFER. WE NEED THE GOAL OF THIS
POST MAY IT RIGHT BUT BEHAVE
PRINT. FOR DRIVERS WHEN THEY
APPROACH BEST SIGN. ALL ROADS
LEAD TO BE FREE FOR ALL ROAD
USERS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IPHONE. TESTIFYING
TODAY. IN PERSON AND THE
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS DAVE
SNYDER. FROM CAL BIKE THE
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND WE HAVE IN
HERE IN PERSON MR SCHNEIDER GO
RIGHT AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU
AS A MEMBER BORDER HER VOTE
FOR. THE MOVING THIS FORWARD
INTO THAT THAT COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS FOR WORKING SO HARD
ON THIS. HI MY NAME IS DAVE
SNYDER I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
BICYCLE COALITION. WHEN WE
FIRST CONSIDER THIS LAW YEARS
AGO. THAT WE CALLED IT THE
IDAHO STOP AND OUR MOTIVATION
WAS PROBABLY SIMILAR TO THEIRS
AT THE TIME WHEN THEY
INTRODUCED IT TWENTY YEARS AGO.
YOU COULD SAY THOSE ARE
CONSERVATIVE VALUES LET'S GET.
LOST NOBODY OBEYS OFF THE BOOKS
LET'S GIVE DIGNITY TO PEOPLE TO
MAKE THEIR OWN COMMON SENSE AND
SAFE DECISIONS. BUT AS WE DUG
DEEPER THIS YEAR WE CONSIDERED
CALLING IT. DOES TAKE YOUR
TURN. BECAUSE REALLY IT'S ABOUT
EVERYONE TAKING THEIR TURN AT
THE INTERSECTION. BUT WHEN WE
DISCOVERED HOW THIS WILL
IMPROVE SAFETY WE CALL IT THE
SAFETY STUFF. AND THAT'S WHAT
IT'S CALLED ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY AND I THINK THAT
EXPLAINS WHY. A LOT OF LIBERAL
STATES HAVE JOINED CONSERVATIVE
STATES AND SUPPORTING THIS-
THE- WHEN WE LOOK AT THE SAFETY
I HONESTLY EXPECTED JUST TO SEE
NO. MORE DANGER I EXPECTED IT
TO STAY THE SAME. AND IN FACT
EVERYWHERE THIS LAW HAS BEEN
PASSED. THERE'S NO SAFETY
PROBLEMS WHATSOEVER NO EVIDENCE
THAT CRASHES INCREASED AND NOT
EVEN ANY COMPLAINTS. BUT IN
FACT WE FOUND THAT IT MAKES IT
SAFER AS THE SEVEN MEMBER
POINTED OUT IN DELAWARE
CREDIBLE DATA FROM THEIR POLICE
DEPARTMENT. SHOWED A 23%
REDUCTION IN CRASHES THAT STOP
SIGN INTERSECTIONS. I HAVE SOME
THEORIES AS TO WHY. THAT MIGHT
BE AT AND TALKING TO PEOPLE.
ONE IS OF COURSE THE- REDUCED
EXPO OSIER THAT HE SENT TO ME
MENTION. ANOTHER IS THAT A YOU
GET TO. YOUR MOMENTUM ACROSS IT
INTERSECTION. YOU HAVE A BETTER
OPPORTUNITY GET OUT OF THE WAY
OF A SPEEDING CAR. ITSELF MIGHT
BE RUNNING THE STOP SIGN. SO
REGARDLESS OF THE REASON THIS
IS DEFINITELY AN IMPROVEMENT IN
SAFETY AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE SAFETY STUFF. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SNYDER THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE- SO WITH
THAT WE WILL GO BACK TO THE
GALLERY TO SEE IF THERE ANYONE
THERE'S ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. C. NONE WILL GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE IN SUPPORT CNN.
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANYONE IN
THE CONFERENCE LINE IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY ONE TWENTY TWO PLEASE.
ONE MOMENT MADAM CHAIR IF YOU'D
LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR A. B.
ONE TWENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD TO BE PROVIDED YOUR LINE
NUMBER. WE DO HAVE SOME ALREADY
THAT ARE IN QUEUE WE'LL BEGIN
WITH LINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE
THAT'S TWO NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS JONATHAN
CLAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
EVENTS NEED US IN SUPPORT OF A
B. ONE TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
SIX COMMENT WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FIFTY THREE THAT'S FIVE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING I'M SURE NUMBERS TO
KEEP A KARATE BUT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. SIX
COME UP OVER THE LINE NUMBER
FORTY EIGHT THAT'S FOUR EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MA'AM SURE MEMBERS ROSS BARKLEY
ON THE APP THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. WHEN I
WOULD- I NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT TO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS JAMES OF OUR
JUNIOR WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION ABIDE IN
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. NEXT CALL OVER THE LINE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE THAT'S TWO
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS AGAIN- YES WE
WOULD SHOW YOUR HANDS WE SHOULD
LOVE TRAVELING. ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT
COME UP WITH A LINE NUMBER
FORTY TWO BEDS FOR TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE MAN IN THE
CHAIR THANK YOU- MEMBERS
MICHAEL NOCERA IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY TWO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. SIX COMMENT LINE NUMBER
FORTY SEVEN FOUR SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ROGER
DICKINSON FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. WHAT A
LINE NUMBER FIFTY THAT'S FIVE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
MEDICATION- ON THE- THE FISH-
FOUR STREETS FOR ALL- LA COUNTY
ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT
THANKS. THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. WHAT A LINE NUMBER
THIRTY THAT'S THREE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MICHAEL STANDARD
MISTREATS WORLD WHAT CAN JUST
RESTORE CALLS ON SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. I'M
SURE WE HAVE EXHAUSTED THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR- SO NOW WE'LL MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
AB ONE TWENTY TWO IT LOOKS LIKE
WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
ONE WHO IS- IN PERSON MISTER
STEVE BARROW CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR CHILDREN'S SAFETY
AND HEALTH. OF MR BARELY MAKE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
MY NAME IS STEVE BARROW ON THE
STATE PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
CHILDREN'S SAFETY AND HEALTH OF
THE WORKING ON TRAFFIC SAFETY
THE CHILDREN'S HEALTH ISSUES
FOR THIRTY SOME YEARS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- WE'RE IN WE'RE
OPPOSED PRIMARILY TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE OF HOW MUCH RISK IT
PUTS ON OUR CHILDREN AND OUR
BICYCLE RIDING CHILDREN. THE
BILL IS NOT BASED ON ANY
PUBLISHED PEER REVIEWED
STUDIES. AND EVEN THOUGH THEY
MAKE CLAIMS THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
SUPPORTING THE BILL MAKE CLAIMS
THAT THIS WILL. INCREASE SAFETY
THERE IS NO PUBLISHED REVIEW
PEER REVIEWED STUDY THAT SHOWS
THAT. MATTER OF FACT THE RECENT
PUBLISHED STUDIES OF BICYCLE
CRASH FATALITIES IN THE UNITED
STATES. SHOWS AT DELAWARE AND
CALIFORNIA PART TWO OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS PLACES TO RIDE. WHEN
YOU TALK TO THE TRAUMA CENTERS
IN DELAWARE. YEAH I'M ON THE
EMS COMMISSION AND SO WE
COMMUNICATE WITH WITH TRAUMA
CENTERS ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
THE TRAUMA CENTERS WILL TELL
YOU THAT YEAH. WE HAVEN'T HAD A
LOT MORE CRASHES BUT THE
CRASHES WE HAVE AT THE
INTERSECTIONS. ARE FAR MORE
SEVERE. THAN WE'VE EVER SEEN
AND THAT'S PROBABLY BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE BOLDLY GOING OUT
THROUGH THE STOP SIGN. WITHOUT
TAKING PRECAUTIONS WITH THE
TRAFFIC COMING. WE ARE HAVE
HUNDREDS OF BICYCLE FATALITIES
IN CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OF HOSPITALIZED
BICYCLE RIDERS WITH. TRAUMATIC
BRAIN INJURIES IN CALIFORNIA
THIS BILL WILL INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE HERE
ESPECIALLY CHILDREN CHILDREN
ARE NOT EXPERIENCED AT. HOW FAR
A CAR HAS TO BE AWAY BEFORE WE
GET TOO OLD WHEN THEY GO
THROUGH A STOP SIGN. THE
REALITY IS THAT SOME PEOPLE
WILL SLOW UP AS THE AUTHOR HAS
SAID. AND LOOK AND MAKE SURE
IT'S SAFE. BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT THERE'S MILLIONS OF
DRIVERS ON THE ROADS IN
CALIFORNIA MILLIONS
PEDESTRIANS. MILLIONS OF.
DELIVERY TRUCKS FIRST
RESPONDERS. WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS
THAT. BICYCLE RIDERS THAT WANT
TO JUST GO THROUGH THE STOP
SIGN WILL BE FEEL EMBOLDENED.
ARE BUSY ALREADY- CONGESTED
STREETS OR NOT A SAFE PLACE TO
DO THAT IT IS- SPECIALLY NOT
SAFE FOR CHILDREN. IF THIS BILL
IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO MOVE.
CHILDREN SHOULD BE REMOVED IF
WE WANT ADULTS TO TRY TO
EXERCISE THIS. THAT'S ONE THING
BUT ASKING CHILDREN WHO HAVE
NEVER DRIVEN A CAR I. DON'T
KNOW HOW TO NAVIGATE THROUGH
TRAFFIC WE SPENT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TEACHING THEM HOW TO.
BE SAFE IN TRAFFIC AND THEN TO
TURN AROUND AND TELL HIM- IT'S
OKAY FOR YOU. EIGHT YEAR OLD
SIX YEAR OLD TEN YEAR OLD TO
RIDE THROUGH. A STOP SIGN IS.
IS NOT THE WAY TO GO. I THANK
YOU MR BERRA WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO YOU'D LIKE TO WRAP THE
RETURN. WORLD WE THINK THAT THE
BILLS GOING TO MOVE YOUR AT
LEAST HAVE TO PROTECT THE
CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIA. MAKE
THIS AN ADULT ISSUE BECAUSE
THEY ARE EXPERIENCE WITH
TRAFFIC IT IS GOING TO MAKE IT
THAT RISK FOR THEM TOO. BUT AT
LEAST WE DON'T HAVE CHILDREN
BEING HARMED BECAUSE OF THIS
MISGUIDED THERE HAS BEEN
STUDIES NO PUBLISHED PEER
REVIEW PAPER ON THIS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR BROKERS YOU BEING
HERE IN PERSON- WE HAVE ANOTHER
PRIMARY WITNESS AN OPPOSITION
DR SHANNON CASTLE. A PEDIATRIC
SURGEON ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF
TRAUMA VALLEY CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL I BELIEVE- DOCTOR
SHANNON CASTLE IS ON THE
COASTLINE MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE ENSURE THAT THE DOCTORS
ON THE LINE PLEASE. YES DOCTOR
CANCEL YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I'M DOCTOR
SHANNON CASTLE PEDIATRIC
SURGEON TRAUMA SURGEON OF
BALLOTS AND HOSPITAL IN MADERA
IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA I'VE
TREATED TRAUMA VICTIMS
THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN AND CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA FOR. MY ENTIRE
CAREER I'M ALSO AN AVID ROAD
CYCLIST AND I BRING MY BIKE IN
URBAN AND RURAL ENVIRONMENTS
THROUGH THE ENTIRE STATE I PUT
THIS BILL PRETTY CAREFULLY AS A
SURGEON AND AS A CYCLIST- WE
HAVE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
CYCLISTS EVERY YEAR DYING
CALIFORNIA AND ACCIDENTS WITH
CARS- AD YOU KNOW COUNTLESS
MORE ARE SERIOUSLY INJURED WITH
MANY OF THESE THAT I SEE BEING
SEVERE HEAD INJURIES. I TAKING
CARE OF THESE CHILDREN I'VE
BEEN HIT MYSELF I'VE BEEN HIT
IN INTERSECTIONS- PROPONENTS OF
THIS BILL ARE CLAIMING THEY
YIELDING IT ASSIGNED RATHER
THAN STOPPING CAN BE JUST A
SAVE THE DATE ON THESE. ARE
UNFORTUNATELY PRETTY WEAK- AND
I KNOW FROM BEING A TEN
THOUSAND MILES A YEAR ON A BIKE
THAT IT'S OFTEN IMPOSSIBLE TO
JUDGE AN INTERSECTION WHEN
YOU'RE GOING AT SPEED AND THAT
CAN BE VERY SUBJECTIVE-
CHILDREN ESPECIALLY DURING THE
FULL MEANING OF A STOP SIGN AND
TREATING THEM AS A YIELD SIGN
WITHOUT THE MATURITY OR THE
BIKE HANDLING SKILLS TO JUDGE
THIS AS AS I WOULD CONCEDE.
MANY ADULT CYCLISTS BLACK AS
WELL IS A IS A RECIPE. FOR
INJURY AND DEATH. I FULLY
SHARED WITH THE BY. AT THE-
ADVOCACY GROUP THAT WE SHOULD
CREATE A SAY AND- FOR CYCLISTS.
AND ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO RIDE-
BUT I FEEL THAT IN THE CURRENT
WRITING ENVIRONMENT OUR STAGE
CHILDREN TREATING STOP SIGNS
THE STOPS JUSTICE CARS KEEPS
THEM THE STATE THAT THEY DON'T
WANT TO SEE ANY MORE KIDS.
COMING TO MY DRAWING THEIR
WORST NOT EVEN MAKE IT INTO THE
TRAUMA BAY. AND SO THIS AS AS
HE POINTED OUT I DO NOT BELIEVE
SHOULD APPLY TO CHILDREN. THANK
YOU DR CASTLE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- WITNESS YOUR- THE
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME SO NOW
WE'LL GO BACK TO THE GALLERY IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER WITNESSES
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY ONE TO
TWENTY TWO C. NINE ROOM ONE
TWELVE. THE NUN- MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO
ONE TWENTY TWO ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE PLEASE. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ON A. B. ONE TWENTY
TWO YOU MAY PUT YOURSELF IN
QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AND
MADAM CHAIR AFTER ALLOWING A
FEW MOMENTS THERE IS NO ONE
QUEUING UP IN OPPOSITION OF AB
ONE TWENTY TWO AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATORS SO WE'LL TAKE IT
BACK TO MEMBERS- SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- THE
AUTHOR AND I'VE HAD A
CONVERSATION BUT I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THIS DOES NOT
IN ANY WAY ABROGATE THE CIVIL
RESPONSIBILITY LIABILITY OF A
BICYCLIST WHO FAILS TO YIELD.
THAT STANDARD OF DUE CARE
REMAINS EXACTLY THE SAME AS IT
IS TODAY IS THAT RIGHT THAT'S
EXACTLY CORRECT SENATOR UMBERG
IN THE SAME THING GOES WITH
RESPECT TO. THE CITATION FOR
CRIMINAL VIOLATIONS FOR EXAMPLE%
THAT STANDARD REMAINS EXACTLY
THE SAME THE STANDARD REMAINS
THE SAME IN A UNDERSTANDING
THAT YOU ARE CONSIDERING ADDING
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S- NO AMBIGUITY
IN THAT ISSUE. I AM SENATOR
UMBERG THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUGGESTED LANGUAGE AND WE JUST
RECEIVED IT THIS MORNING AND
WILL BE TAKING A LOOK AT THAT
AND SEE IF WE CAN ADD THAT IN A
IN A FUTURE STEP IN THIS
PROCESS RT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR UMBERG SENATOR
NEWMAN AND THEN SENATOR BAKER.
YEAH THANK YOU VENTURE-
ADDITIONALLY WOMAN BURNED HER
RETINA HD WHEN I'VE SPOKEN AT
LENGTH ABOUT THIS MESS AS
YOU'RE AWARE I WAS A SKEPTIC-
WHEN I WHEN I FIRST INTRODUCED
YOUR BILL YEAH AND I'VE I'VE
COME AROUND BUT I DO TAKE
SERIOUSLY MR BARROW- AND THE
PHYSICIANS COMMENTS AND
CONCERNS ABOUT CHILDREN WHICH
WOULD YOU MIND SPEAKING. TO
THEIR CONCERN AND YOU KNOW TO
THE POSSIBILITY OF MAKING A
DIFFERENTIATION BETWEEN-
CHILDREN OR UNDER EIGHTEEN
BICYCLISTS AND THOSE WHO ARE
ADULTS. SURE- I THINK MY
BIGGEST POINT IS THE DATA THAT
WE'VE HAD. AND ESPECIALLY FROM
DELAWARE SO EVERY SEAT IS
COLLECTED DATA THE MOST ROBUST
DATA WE HAVE IS FROM DELAWARE
AND THAT SHOWS A 23% REDUCTION
BETWEEN BIKE CAR COLLISIONS AT
STOP SIGNS WHEN. LAW LIKE
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY TWO IS.
ENACTED AND I AS A MOTHER WOULD
LIKE TO KEEP MY CHILDREN SAFE
TO. AND SO I'VE TAUGHT MY
CHILDREN MY SON HAS BEEN BIKING
SINCE HE WAS THREE YEARS OLD
HE'S BEEN BACK INTO SCHOOL
SINCE HE'S FIVE CROSSING. STOP
SIGNS AT INTERSECTIONS CHILDREN
ARE THEY HERE LEARN YIELDING
FROM THE TIME WE WOULD TEACH
THEM TO LOOK BOTH WAYS AND
CROSS THE ROAD. THAT'S WHAT WE
DO AS PARENTS WE TEACH THEM TO
BE SAFE YEAH SO WHEN AS WE GO
THROUGH. AND WE LOOK AT THIS
YOU KNOW ONE THING THAT IS AN
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY TWO THE OTHER
STATES HAVE NOT DONE AS WE HAVE
THIS VERY ROBUST STUDY THAT
WILL COME BACK. THAT WILL SHOW
US- WHAT THE DATA ON THE SAFETY
IS BUT THERE IS NO INDICATION
THAT CHILDREN ARE LESS SAFE AT
INTERSECTIONS. BUT YIELDING
THAN STOPPING AND THERE'S
NOTHING FROM RECRUITING PARENTS
FROM TELLING THEIR CHILDREN
THAT THEY SHOULD STOP RATHER
THAN YIELD RIGHT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT MINORS IT'S A PARENTAL
RESPONSIBILITY THE THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. AND EVERY KID
IS DIFFERENT MY SON ADAM HAS
BEEN READY SINCE HE WAS THREE
MY DAUGHTER STARTED WRITING
WHEN SHE WAS FIVE. BOTH OF THEM
BUT I CAN BIKE AND WALK TO
SCHOOL. AND THEY GO THROUGH A
STOP SIGN. AND I'VE TAUGHT MY
CHILDREN TO YIELD BECAUSE WHEN
THEY'RE ON THE BIKE THEY'RE
TALLER THEY'RE BIGGER THEY'RE
MORE VISIBLE WHEN THEY GOT OFF
THEIR BIKES. THEY ARE NOT
VISIBLE NEXT TO A CAR. AND SO
THE SLOW AND THEY EVALUATE THE
INTERSECTION AND THESE KIDS ARE
ON THE ROLLED ROAD ANYWAYS. YOU
KNOW THE IDEA THAT KIDS KEEP
KIDS ARE BIKING UNDER SIXTEEN.
I CAN'T FOLLOW TRAFFIC RULES IS
THAT THE FAULT OF THE PARENTS
WHO HAVEN'T TAUGHT THEM HOW TO
STAY SAFE. SO I DO THINK THAT
IS A PARENTAL RESPONSIBILITY
AND THERE'S NOTHING IN EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY TWO THAT WOULD MAKE
CHILDREN LESS SAFE IN FACT IT
MAKES THEM SAFER. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT I WOULD JUST
ADD FOR THE RECORD THAT BY THE
FIVE YEAR OLD SHE HAS NO COMMON
SENSE WHATSOEVER. SHE SHOULD BE
BACK TO SCHOOL. MAYBE SHOULD
HAVE BETTER BETTER PARENTING- I
HAVE A QUESTION IT DONE ON
BEHALF OF MY- ON BEHALF OF MY
COFFEE. HERE IT'S TOO LATE.
IT'S ON THE RECORD. I IT'S AN
ARDUOUS A IT IS. TO USE CASE IT
HAD LIKE A SPEAK TO. WE HAD YOU
FOR WAY STOP. YEAH EVERY CAR
STOP. YEAH AND YOU'VE GOT A
BIKE CLUB COMING THROUGH WE'VE
GOT FIFTEEN TO TWENTY BIKERS
ALL TOGETHER COMING TO A FOUR
WAY INTERSECTION. HOW DOES THIS
BILL TREAT THAT SCENARIO. EACH
ONE OF THOSE BIKES MUST YIELD
THEY CANNOT BLOW THROUGH AS
AGAIN BLOWING THROUGH. A STOP
SIGN ROLLING THROUGH A STOP
SIGN IS NOT ALLOWED UNDER
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY TWO. EACH ONE
OF THOSE CYCLISTS WOULD HAVE TO
YIELD AS THEY COME. SO THE EACH
WHOEVER'S IN THE FRONT THE
YIELD THEY GO THE OTHER CARS
GO. THAT'S HOW IT WORKS TO BE
CLEAR THAT THEY THEY THINK
COULD NOT AND LEGALLY SHOULD
NOT TREAT THIS AS A LICENSE FOR
ALL OF THEM. TO GO THROUGH THAT
ABSOLUTELY NOT THAT'S A LEGAL
NON B. I'VE LEGAL UNDER ONE
TWENTY TWO AS PATIENT THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN FOR A QUESTION SENATOR
PACKARD WILL GO TO SENATOR
RUBIO NEXT. I THINK YOU WOULD
COMMEND THE AUTHOR AND I WANT
TO. EMPHASIZE AGAIN THE
ARGUMENTS- FROM THE COMMITTEE
NOW ASSISTANCE TO THE SAFETY
STOP DOES NOT CHANGE THE NUMBER
YOUR RULES OF GILDING
INTERSECTION. PEOPLE ON BIKES
WILL STILL BE REQUIRED TO YIELD
TO PEDESTRIANS AND OTHER
TRAFFIC AN INTERSECTION FOR
APPROACHING INTERSECTION WITH
THE RIGHT OF WAY. IT'S ME
LEGALIZES A COMMON PRACTICE
WHICH IS TO SLOW DOWN AS A
PORTION OR SECTION CHECK FOR
TRAFFIC PROCEEDED AS SAFE. AND
STOP IT IS NOT SO. I THINK YOU
KNOW EVIDENCE AND OTHER STATES
SHOWS THAT THIS INCREASES
SAFETY. I MEAN WHAT ARE OUR
KIDS BE SAFE TOO AND I. SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE REMOVE IT WHEN.
THIS PROGRAM THANK YOU SENATOR
BAKER MOVED BY CENTER BACK OR
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- I ALSO. WANT TO EXPRESS
MY CONCERN SO YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN. IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR ABOUT MY CONCERNS THAT
SAFETY CONCERNS FOR CHILDREN
AND I ALREADY- YOU KNOW I WANT
TO ECHO SOME OF THE CONCERNS
HERE I BELIEVE MR- REQUEST
SOMEONE THAT EXPRESSED MY
CONCERNS. ARE NO MORE LINES WAY
BUT I DO HAVE CONCERNS AND EVEN
COMING TO THE FLOOR HAD
CONCERNS AND I HAD TO EXPRESS
THEM TO THE AUTHOR BUT WHEN I
HEAR COMMENTS LIKE YOU KNOW
IT'S PARENTAL RESPONSIBILITY
IT'S THE PARENTS FAULT IF THEY
DON'T KNOW HOW TO. CROSS I
THINK THERE'S A DISCONNECT HERE
BECAUSE THAT MAKES THE
ASSUMPTION THAT EVERY CHILD
GROWS UP WITH THE BICYCLE AND
THEY DON'T THAT EVERY PARENT IS
OUT BICYCLING WITH THEIR
CHILDREN ARE AVID BICYCLIST AND
THAT'S NOT THE REALITY THERE'S
SOME HOMES WHERE CHILDREN HAVE
NEVER SEEN A BIKE AND THEY'RE
ONLY ABLE TO USE IT OUTSIDE
WHEN THERE'S FRIENDS AND- AGAIN
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
DISCONNECT HERE BECAUSE NOT
EVERY CHILD HAS A BIKE NOT
EVERY CHILD CAN AFFORD A BIKE.
AND NOT EVERY PARENT IS OFTEN
ENOUGH TO HAVE A BIKE AND
BICYCLE EVERYTHING- IF WE CAN
WITH THEIR CHILDREN SO I DO
WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO
CONSIDER WHAT SOME AT THE
OPPOSITIONIST SAYING ABOUT THE
YOUNGER CHILDREN PERHAPS NOT
EIGHTEEN BUT YOU KNOW FOURTEEN
OR LESS FIFTEEN OR LESS I THINK
THAT THERE IS A REAL CONCERN
HERE AND- AND I SAID I WOULD
SUPPORT THIS BILL WITH.
RESERVATIONS BECAUSE I KNOW
SHE'S WORKED REALLY HARD ON
THIS BUT IT IS VALID I DO WANT
TO VALIDATE THE CONCERNS OF
THOSE HAD SPOKE IN OPPOSITION
BECAUSE I HAVE THE SAME EXACT
CONCERNS AND I KNOW THAT IT
WILL CONTINUE TO MOVE THROUGH
THE PROCESS AND I HOPE THAT
SHE'S OPEN TO THOSE DISCUSSIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO SENATOR MELINDA S. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- FIRST PRIDE. I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
AUTHOR IS TRYING TO MAKE IT A
SAFER ENVIRONMENT FOR CYCLISTS
OUT THERE. BUT I. DO HAVE GREAT
CONCERN ABOUT. CHILDREN IN THIS
REGARD- AND I KNOW THAT
ASSEMBLYWOMAN YOU HAVE STATED
THAT YOU TEACH YOUR CHILDREN
THE RIGHT WAY TO RIDE A BIKE
AND HOW TO OBEY. THE RULES OF
THE ROAD OUT THERE BUT IF-
FIRST OF ALL NOT EVERY PARENT
IS TEACHING THEIR KIDS THEIR
SIN EVEN THOUGH WE MAY SAY WELL
THAT'S BAD PARENTING THAT'S NOT
GOING TO CHANGE THE FACT THAT
THEY MAY GET KILLED OUT THERE
BECAUSE- THEY DIDN'T FOLLOW THE
RULES OF THE ROAD SECONDLY. YOU
KNOW IT JUST GET ON TECH TALK
AND YOU WILL SEE A VARIETY OF
WAYS IN WHICH CHILDREN ARE NOT
DOING THE THINGS THAT THEIR
PARENTS. HAVE TAUGHT THEM SO
KIDS ARE JUST YOU KNOW THEIR
KIDS THEY'RE NOT AS MATURE. IN
THEIR DECISION MAKING PROCESS
SEES AS ADULTS ARE IN A NIGHT.
I AM VERY WORRIED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT. ANY KID OF ANY AGE
OUT THERE IN A BICYCLE WE'LL BE
ABLE TO DO THIS AND THAT WE ARE
EXPECTING THEM TO BE ABLE TO
DISCERN. WHAT'S SAFE AND WHAT
ISN'T SAFE IN A SITUATION WHERE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT CARS THAT.
EIGHT I MEAN. THESE KIDS ARE
GONNA GET KILLED IF THEY DON'T
MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION AN
APPARENT ISN'T THERE TO GUIDE
THEM SO IT WOULD BE MY
PREFERENCE IF THE BILL HAD IS
SOME SORT OF YOU KNOW AGE
MINIMUM FOR WHICH TO OBEY THESE
PARTICULAR ROLES I STILL THINK
IT'S- LARGELY CAN BE UNSAFE FOR
ADULTS AS WELL BECAUSE THEY
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THE CARS
ARE GOING TO DO IN THE ONCOMING
TRAFFIC BUT I LEAST THINK WOULD
BE SAFER. IF WE RESTRICTED IT
TO A CERTAIN AGE RATHER THAN.
HANGING OUT IN CHILDREN AS
YOUNG AS THREE APPARENTLY OF
SOME OF HIM WHO ARE ON BICYCLES
SO I DO APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO BUT AGAIN SOME OF
THE STATES THAT WERE USED AS A
REFERENCE FOR INSTANCE
DELAWARE. DELAWARE'S ENTIRE
STATE POPULATION IS LESS THAN A
MILLION WE FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA WITH A LOT MORE
CARS ON THE ROAD A LOT MORE
CYCLISTS ON THE ROAD A LOT MORE
CONTRACTED CONGESTION AND I
DON'T THINK IT'S A FAIR
COMPARISON. TO COMPARE IT TO A
STATE LIKE IDAHO OR SOUTH
DAKOTA. OR CITIES OTHER STATES
WHICH HAVE AS MUCH SMALLER
POPULATIONS UNFORTUNATELY- I
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY BUT I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MELINDA IS I
SEE NO OTHER MIKES UP WHAT I
WILL SAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN VERY
DEDICATED. TO WORKING WITH OUR
COMMITTEE AND TO ENSURING THAT
SAFETY IS ALWAYS FIRST- I THINK
THIS IS FAIR IN THE SENSE THAT
YOU'VE HEARD THE CONCERNS I
KNOW YOU'LL CONTINUE WORKING ON
THIS WITH MANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS A FIVE YEAR
PILOT- WITH A ROBUST SAFETY
REPORT COMING BACK TO US- VIA
THE C. H. P. BY TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN- SO IT I THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THAT WORK AND FOR YOUR
SPONSORS WORK TOO. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES- I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR THIS
CONSIDERATION YOU ALL KNOW THIS
IS VERY- HUGE PASSION OF MINE
AND I'M AN AVID BICYCLIST- WE
BIKE RIDE AS A FAMILY AND WHEN.
WE LOOK AT THE CURRENT
SITUATION THE STATUS QUO
DOESN'T MAKE OUR KIDS. AND OUR
CYCLISTS ANY STAY FOR WE KNOW
FROM STATES FROM SEATTLE TO
DELAWARE. THAT- HAVING BIKE IS
HEALED DOES MAKE IT SAFER I
HAVE HEARD YOUR CONCERNS AND I
WILL CONTINUE WORKING WITH EACH
OF YOU SHOULD YOU SO CHOOSE AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
HAVE A- THANK YOU SEMI MEMBER
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE I'M SORRY THIS IS MOVED
BY SENATOR BECKER. MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THIRTEEN DOLLARS FIVE DOLLARS
HI BATES. ALAN ARCHULETA MARCH
LETTER HI BECKER BECKER HI
CORTESE CORTESE II DOLLY ALI NO
DOT. DODD HI WHERE REQUIRE HIGH
BLOOD THIS BELINDA'S NO MAN.
MAN HI NORMAN NEWMAN HI RUBIO.
RUBIO HI SKINNER. HUMBERT
HUMBERT HI CASKEY KELSEY HI
WILL. ELEVEN TWO THANK YOU THIS
HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET UP AND
LEAVE IT ON CALL THANK YOU SOME
REMEMBER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARD. WHO JOINED US FOR EIGHTY
NINE FIFTY THIS IS FILE ITEM.
FIVE WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WORK. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS- IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN GOVERNOR NEWSOM ORDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT TO IDENTIFY
AND PRIORITIZE ACCESS STATE
OWNED PROPERTY AND AGGRESSIVELY
PURSUE SUSTAINABLE INNOVATIVE
AND COST EFFECTIVE HOUSING
PROJECTS HOWEVER EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES THAT WINDY CITY OR
COUNTY EXPRESSES AN INTEREST IN
PURCHASING THESE PARCELS
AGENCIES LIKE CALTRANS MUST
SELL THE PROPERTY AT FAIR
MARKET VALUE WHICH PREFIX HUGE
COST TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. EIGHTY NINE FIFTY
HELP THIS ISSUE BY AUTHORIZING
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION TO SELL EXCESS
PROPERTY TO CITIES AND COUNTIES
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF LONG
TERM AFFORDABLE HOUSING
EMERGENCY SHELTERS OR FEEDING
PROGRAMS AT THE PROPERTY'S
ORIGINAL ACQUISITION VALUE
FACILITATING THE TRANSFER OF
STRATEGICALLY LOCATED EXCESS
LAND FOR THE USE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DIRECTLY PROVIDES A
TOOL TO ADDRESS THE STATE'S
HOUSING PRICES REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS AND SPUR JOB
GROWTH DRUG JOB GROWTH ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. ONLINE WE HAVE
DANNY GOES TO IS THE ASSISTANT
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SOMEBODY
MEMBER- MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE
MR YOST ON THE LINE FROM
CALTRANS PLEASE. YES WITNESS
USE YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS HI MY NAME IS DANIELLE
AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATION FOR CATHERINE.
CALTRANS IS PROUD TO SPONSOR
THIS BILL THIS YEAR WE RECENTLY
RELEASED A NEW STRATEGIC PLAN
WITH THE STATED GOAL OF
ADVANCING EQUITY AND ABILITY
AND ALL COMMUNITIES. IT IS
THROUGH THIS PLAN THE CALTRANS
RECOGNIZED AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PUT THE LAND ITSELF TO BETTER
USE HELPING OUR COMMUNITIES
ADDRESSED THE PORTABLE HOUSING
CRISIS. ANY LOCALITIES APPROACH
CONTENT ABOUT ACQUIRING
DEPARTMENT EXCEPT PLANNED. FOR
THE GOLDEN FILLED PROVIDE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO DEVELOP MORE
LONG TERM AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BYE BYE PROVIDING FLEXIBILITY
FOR THE USE OF CALTRANS
PROPERTIES. THE BILL ALSO
ALLOWS THE LAND TO BE USED FOR
EMERGENCY SHELTERS AND
NAVIGATION CENTERS PROVIDING
SERVICES TO PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US SO. THAT WAS
YOUR PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT- GO TO THE GALLERY TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY NINE FIFTY
C. NINE ROOM ONE TWELVE. WE SEE
NONE. WE'LL GO BACK TO YOUR
MODERATOR ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY NINE FIFTY PLEASE. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE FIFTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN FOUR SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M SHARING
MEMBERS THAT ROGER DICKINSON ON
BEHALF OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. NUMBER
ONE NUMBER FIFTY THAT'S. FIVE
ZERO. FIVE FIFTY OR ONE IS OPEN
CAN YOU CHECK YOUR LINE FOR
SELF MUTE. HEARING A RESPONSE
FROM THAT LINE WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON TO ONE NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT THAT'S THREE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MODERATOR. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL WE ARE SUPPOSED
TO PREVENT IT. EXCUSE ME
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED. REGARDING
MORE STUFF TO THE LANGUAGE
AROUND THE INTERNET LANGUAGE
WAS KILLED IN TRAINING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. AND WE HAVE EXHAUSTED
THE COMIC YOU AT THIS TIME
MEDICARE. GREAT THANK YOU- SO
NOW WE'LL TAKE IT TO OPPOSITION
WE DON'T HAVE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
NINE FIFTY. PLACE YOURSELF INTO
Q. AN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY NINE
FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WHAT LITTLE LIGHT NUMBER THIRTY
SEVEN THAT'S THREE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS MARK'S DIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP-
WE APPRECIATE IF SOMEONE WERE
TO GOING TO COURT WHILE THE
CHAMPION AND SUPPORTED THE
ORIGINAL VERSION OF THIS BILL.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO THE RECENT
AMENDMENT TO THE STATE INTENDS
TO REQUIRE SKILLED INTERMITTENT
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE COST OF THAT
REQUIREMENT WOULD OUTWEIGH THE
BENEFITS OF. REDUCING THE PRICE
OF THE LAND- FOOTBALL HOW CAN
HELP WHICH WOULD BE BETTER OFF
PAYING FOR THE FULL PRICE OF
THE LAND. THE BILL- IT'S JUST
SO AMENDED WOULD BEGIN THAT
NEGATIVE SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ALL TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE- THIS IS OF GREAT
CONCERN TO US THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS- NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE OF OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
NINE FIFTY AT THIS TIME OKAY
THANK YOU WE'VE DONE BOTH
SUPPORT AND OPPOSE FOR A. B.
NINE FIFTY SO WE'LL TAKE IT
BACK TO MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
SENATOR DELHI. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. OF NICE TO MEET YOU. I
GOT A QUESTION SO THIS THIS
PROPERTY WAS. ACQUIRED IN THE
CEILING BY EMINENT DOMAIN AT
SOME POINT FOR- THE RIGHTS FOR
ALL PUBLIC TO USE IS THAT IS
THAT CORRECT. THAT'S CORRECT
SENATOR KEVIN CARD FOR A NUMBER
OF REASONS. SO I'M I'M A HUGE.
FAN OF PRIVATE PROPERTY RIGHTS
AND ALL AND ALSO UNDERSTAND
INTIMATED THAT MEANS THAT IT'S
GOOD FOR THE PUBLIC AND THAT'S
WHY YOU LOSE YOUR PRIVATE
PROPERTY RIGHT WHEN THEY TAKE
IT BY CONDEMNATION. SO AS THIS
LAND BEEN- OFFERED BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL PEOPLE THAT IT WAS
TAKEN FROM FOR A PUBLIC USE. SO
THIS LAND- WHATEVER TRANSPIRED
DECADES AGO AND IS NOW WITHIN
THE PUBLIC- PORTFOLIO AND IT
WILL DO ALL THIS BILL DOES IS
MAKE SURE THAT IF WE'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO OFFER THAT TO
CITIES OR COUNTIES FOR
DIFFERENT PUBLIC PURSES. BY
PURPOSE THE PROVISION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT WE CAN
USE THE ORIGINAL ACQUISITION
VALUE AS OPPOSED TO TODAY'S FOR
FAIR MARKET VALUE. IT'S A IT'S
A COST SAVING MEASURE FOR
AFFORDABLE I UNDERSTAND WHERE
YOU'RE GOING BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT. THAT WHEN THAT LAND
ORIGINALLY WAS TAKEN FROM THE
PRIVATE. OWNERS IT WAS DESIGNED
IT WAS USED FOR TRANSPORTATION
I BELIEVE- AND THAT THAT RIGT
IS JUSTIFIED BUT WE WOULDN'T GO
OUT AND CONDEMN SOMEBODY'S
PROPERTY NOW AND TEAR DOWN
THEIR HOME AND SAY WE'RE GONNA
PUT UP PUBLIC HOUSING OR- LOW
INCOME HOUSING SO MY POINT IS
THAT. THE LAND IS NOT IS NOT
BEING USED FOR WHAT IT
ORIGINALLY WAS CONDEMNED FOR
AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO OFFER TO
SOMEBODY ELSE SO THE ORIGINAL
LANDOWNERS SHOULD HAVE THE
OPTION TO GET THEIR LAND BACK
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN. NOT USED FOR
THE ORIGINAL INTENT. AND THE
USE OF EMINENT DOMAIN. I
RESPECT YOUR POINT SENATOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DEAR US
SENATOR DALEY CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU AND I JUST I DO WANT
TO COMMIT THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD AND THERE
ARE MANY REASONS WHY. YOU KNOW
I BELIEVE THIS BILL IS ISN'T
NEEDED- FOR EXAMPLE- I
UNDERSTAND THE COMMON SOUNDS
ARE GREAT SENATOR JUST MADE
ABOUT GIVING IT BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL OWNERS SWEET YOU KNOW
IN MY AREA WE'VE HAD LAND
THAT'S BEEN SITTING THERE. FOR
R. TWENTY THIRTY FORTY YEARS ON
AND THE ORIGINAL INTENT WAS TO
EXTEND FOR EXAMPLE A FREEWAY
AND THROUGHOUT THE YEARS-
FAMILIES AROUND THERE HAD
OPPOSITION TO THE FREEWAY SO
THE FREEWAY NEVER GOT BILLED
BUT WE HAVE SUCH GREAT LAND
JUST SITTING THERE VACANT
UNUSED. AND WE ARE IN A CRISIS
WHERE WE DO NEED HOUSING AND SO
I THINK THIS IS JUST A GOOD WAY
TO GET THOSE UNDER UTILIZED
PROPERTIES IN THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE THAT NEED HOUSING SO I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD WAY TO
HELP OUR COMMUNITIES BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND I WOULD
LIKE TO. COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS AND BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR WHEN APPROPRIATE THANK
YOU GREAT THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO ANY OTHER MY EXCEPT
SENATOR BATES. FROM MY PROBLEM-
WITH THE BILL IS FROM WHERE THE
MONEY'S GOING TO O AFTER THE
PROPERTY IS OFFERED ON A FIRST
REFUSAL TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THE MANY ORIGINALLY IS SUPPOSED
TO GO TO REPLACE THE MONEY THE
I. AND THE HIGHWAY ACCOUNTING
WE CONTINUALLY RAISE TAXES. FOR
ROAD REPAIRS ON GAS AT FEDERAL
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUND
FIVE THAT'D BEEN APPROPRIATED
DURING THAT TIME I'VE BEEN IN
THE SENATE ARE PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT IT WOULD SEEM TO ME
OF WE'RE OING TO APPROVE
SOMETHING THAT ALLOWS A LOWER.
AMOUNT OF FOR THE PROPERTY AT
LEAST THE MONEY SHOULD GO ONTO
THE HIGHWAY COUNSEL FOR THAT.
REASON I REALLY CAN'T SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY. GREAT THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES NO MIKES UP- UP
SENATOR OUT. I JUST WANNA SAY
THAT I'M I'M PREPARED TO VOTE
FOR THE BILL TODAY AND IT HAS
TO DO FOR ME LARGELY BECAUSE
THE TRANSPORTATION ASPECT THIS
BILL IS GOING TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
AND I JUST WANT TO STATE FOR
THE RECORD THAT I'M RESERVING.
THE RIGHT TO MAKE AMENDMENTS
AND PERHAPS EVEN OPPOSE THE
BILL AND BASED ON THE P. Q.
CONSIDERATIONS THAT WILL BE
COMING BEFORE OUR COMMITTEE-
BUT I WILL CERTAINLY BE
SUPPORTING. EDITORS
RECOMMENDATIONS TODAY. GREAT
THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS. C. NINE- THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD- FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I BELIEVE
THEY'RE ABOUT THIRTY PARCELS OR
SO THAT ARE SUITABLE FOR A
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE OTHER BILLS RELATED
TO SPECIFIC LOCATIONS ON WITH
CALTRANS PROPERTY THAT DO NOT
CONFLICT WITH THIS BILL IT'S
COMPLETELY SEPARATE SO- WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THE CENTERS THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE NEXT
COMMITTEE CONSULTING THE
NUMBERS AS WELL AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST- I VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL- I'M SORRY WE NEED A
MOTION ON THE- BILL AB NINE
FIFTY PLEASE FUNCTION. CENTRE
ARCHULETA THANK YOU. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. ADULTS FIVE DOLLARS
HIGH STAKES NO RAIN DATES NOW
ALAN. HI ELLEN HI ARCHULETA
FIVE PARTULA HI SECOND BY
BECKER I PUT EIGHTY FIVE
CORTESE HI KELLY GO DOLLY NO
DOT AND DOT HI. WHERE PICTURES
HELLO THIS IS LINDA IS NOW. HI
MAN HI THANKS NEWMAN HI THE
BILL. WILL BE A HIGH SKINNER.
NUMBER NUMBER BYE BYE CASKEY.
WELL. TEN THREE THANK YOU THIS
LOOKS LIKE IT HAS TO GET UP AND
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER THANK YOU.
GREAT SO NEXT WE'RE ON OUR
FINAL BILL FOR THE DAY. WHICH
IS FILE ITEM SIX AB TWELVE
THIRTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING. WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TEAM THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IT'S
GREAT TO BE HRE LET ME JUST
FIRST THANK. YOU FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE WITH THIS BILL AS
WELL AS YOUR COMMITTEE TEAM. I
MUCH APPRECIATE I'D HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
WHICH CREATE A SEVEN YEAR
SUNSET. IN AD IN ANNUAL
REPORTING PROVISION. BY AB
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT SIXTY
DECRIMINALIZED SAFE WALKING AND
REMOVE UNNECESSARY FINES. UNDER
CURRENT LAW PEDESTRIANS COULD
BE FINED UP TO TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS FOR. JAY WALKING.
EVEN WHEN THERE ARE NO CARS OR
VEHICLES PRESENT. THIS CREATES
A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL BURDEN
AGAINST MANY. WORKING FAMILIES
WHO ARE JUST SIMPLY TRYING TO.
WALK ACROSS THE STREET TO THE
PURCHASE SOMETHING OR GET TO
WORK OR JUST GO ABOUT THEIR
DAILY LIVES. UNFORTUNATELY
THESE LAWS SEEM TO BE ENFORCED
VERY ARBITRARILY. I LIKE MANY
OF US HAVE CROSSED IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE STREET I'VE YET
TO EVER. GET A J. WALKING TO
GIVE NOT THAT YOUNG HOW DOES
SHE GET TO MEET- PUTTING MY
INDIVIDUAL FRIENDS WHO'VE EVER
GOT A JAY WALKING TICKET YET.
DATA SHOWS THAT AFRICAN
AMERICAN CALIFORNIANS OVER FOUR
POINT THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY.
THAN OTHERS TO BE STOPPED FOR
JAYWALKING. SO WHAT THE BILL
DOES IS IT PROHIBITS FINES FOR
CROSSING THE STREET OUTSIDE OF
INTERSECTION WHEN NO CARS OR
VEHICLES ARE PRESENT. ALLOWS
PEDESTRIANS TO SAFELY USE. A
CROSSWALK ON A YELLOW LIGHT. IN
REPEAL THE LAW BUT WHAT SIDE OF
THE PROTESTS MY WALK ON. WHAT
IT DOESN'T DO IS DOES NOT
PERMIT UNSAFE CROSSING WHEN AN
IMMEDIATE HAZARD IS PRESENT AND
IMMEDIATE HAUSER'S DEFINED AS-
WITH VEHICLES EITHER SO NEAR OR
APPROACHING. SO FAST THAT A
REASONABLE PERSON WOULD REALIZE
THAT THERE IS A DANGER OF A
COLLISION. AND THIS IS A LEGAL
DEFINITION SO. LAW ENFORCEMENT
COULD CONTINUE TO ENFORCE
UNSAFE CROSSING THE STREET WE
WANT TO DO IS ENSURE THAT
THERE'S NO ARBITRARY CITATIONS
WHEN INDIVIDUALS ARE JUST ABOUT
GOING ABOUT THEIR DAY TO SIMPLY
CROSS THE STREET TO AGAIN GET
TO THE STORE- WALK. WALK TO
SCHOOL DO ABOUT THIRTY DAILY
DAILY BUSINESS. AND I'M PROUD
TO HAVE TWO WITNESSES- FROM-
CALIFORNIA WALKS AS WELL AS-
JASON SERWIS. WHO'S PERSONALLY
IMPACTED. THANK YOU SOMEBODY
MEMBER WONDERFUL SO WE FIRST
HAVE- FEDERAL IRAQI FROM
CALIFORNIA WALKS ON THE
COASTLINE PLEASE CAN YOU ENSURE
THAT MYSTERY HE IS ON THE LINE.
I DO NOT SHOW THAT LINE
CONNECTED I DO HAVE THE OTHER
WITNESS TO THE BILL HOWEVER
WONDERFUL WE HAVE MISTER G.
SINCE R. S. AS WELL. THE
WITNESS OR IS YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YOU MAY PROCEED. CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN'T. OKAY GREAT
HELLO MY NAME IS JASON FERRIS
I'M A RESIDENT OF NEVADA AND
I'M CURRENTLY HOMELESS IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I WAS CITED
FOR JAYWALKING I WAS IN
DOWNTOWN A LOT OF THE TIME JOB
SEARCH NOT FAR FROM THE TOWN I
LIVE IN. I CROSS THE ROAD MID
BLOCK TO GET TO A RESTAURANT
ACROSS THE STREET THERE ARE NO
CARS NEARBY AND I KNEW IT WAS
SAFE TO CROSS OF COURSE I WOULD
NOT HAVE PROCESS IF YOU WOULD
HAVE PUT ME OR ANYONE ELSE IN
DANGER AS A RULE I DON'T CROSS
THE STREET WHEN CARS ARE COMING
NOT BECAUSE I CAN GET A TICKET
BUT BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO GET
HIT. ONCE I WOULD HAVE. ACROSS
STREET AN OFFICER ON A
MOTORCYCLE SPOTTED ME. WHEN I
GOT TO THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
STREET HE PULLED UP AND STOP ME
YOU CHOSE TO SIGN ME IN A VERY
VISIBLE LOCATION. IN THE MIDDLE
OF A RESTAURANT'S DRIVE THRU
LANE. AS HE CITED ME HE BLOCKED
ENTIRELY. I FOUND THE INCIDENT
HIGHLY EMBARRASSING TO EVERYONE
PASSING BY. I LOOK LIKE A
CRIMINAL EVEN THOUGH ALL I DONE
BUT SAFELY CROSS THE STREET MID
BLOCK. I HAVE ENOUGH EXPERIENCE
TO KNOW THAT DOBSON DIDN'T STOP
ME BECAUSE I WAS JAY WALKING
YOU STOP ME BECAUSE I DIDN'T
LOOK LIKE I BELONG IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD. I HAD MY BIKE
WITH ME AND SOME LUGGAGE. AND
WAS OBVIOUSLY THAT I WAS
HOMELESS. THAT MADE ME A
TARGET. TARGET IN LOBSTER'S
EYES. THE TRUTH IS PEOPLE J.
WALK EVERY DAY THE NEIGHBORHOOD
ACROSS THE STREET. I NEVER GET
SIDE. BAR FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME
PEOPLE WHO STICK OUT. AS A
GROUNDS FOR CITATION. I KNOW
THIS BECAUSE I'VE BEEN TARGETED
WITH MANY PROTECTIONIST
CITATIONS. IN RECENT YEARS I'VE
RECEIVED FOURTEEN TRAFFIC
INFRACTIONS NEAR THE HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENT WHERE I LIVE. I
RECEIVED ALL THE CITATIONS. AS
A PEDESTRIAN. THEY WERE FOR A
HOST OF TRIVIAL OFFENSES AND
THEIR MAIN PURPOSE WAS TO
CONVEY THE MESSAGE THAT I DON'T
BELONG IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
IT'S NOT JUST PEOPLE HOMELESS.
IT'S JUST NOT HOW MOST PEOPLE
WHO RECEIVE JAY WALKING TICKETS
AT THAT. FORM OF HARASSMENT.
IT'S ALSO PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
BLACK PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR.
THEY RECEIVE JAYWALKING
CITATIONS AT A HIGHER. WAY
HIGHER RATE. THAN THE GENERAL
POPULATION. LIKE HOW MUCH
PEOPLE THEY ARE TARGETED.
PRIMARILY FOR LOOKING LIKE THEY
DON'T BELONG. THERE JAY WALKING
IS A TRUE REAL FANCY
CONSEQUENCES THAT FLOW FROM IT
OR ANYTHING BUT INSIGNIFICANT.
BY JAY JAY WALKING CITATION WAS
RESULTED. IN A HUNDRED DOLLARS
A DAY. TO GET HUNG OVER ME AND
MADE IT HARDER FOR ME TO
IMAGINE A FINANCIAL. BE STABLE
FUTURE. THE THAI CITATION ALSO
INTERFERED WITH MY ABILITY TO
DRIVE. THE J. WALKERS SECTORS
AND WAS PART OF THE REASON WHY
MY DRIVER'S LICENSE WAS
SUSPENDED. BECAUSE OF THAT
SUSPENSION. A TOUGH TIME
FINDING THEM. THESE ARE PART OF.
FOR ALMOST ACT. WHEN PEOPLE A
STREET IN THE MAIN THAT THOSE
NO HARM TO ANYONE. THIS NOT
SUFFER FOR IT. THE STICKER
MISSION BUT NO BIG JUST WITH ME
FOR THE OF US. FIXED OR LOW
INCOME THANK HAVE CATASTROPHIC
IMPACTS. NEW ZEALAND DRIVER'S
LICENSE IN JUNE HUNTER OF
DOLLARS A DAY CAN. THIS IS NOT
HOW WE SHOULD BE TREATED
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS IN NEED.
BECAUSE JAY WALKING LOGS. RIGHT
THE POLICE HARASSING OVER
THEY'D LIKE TO LIKE AND BURN
PEOPLE WITH INSURMOUNTABLE DEBT
I URGE YOU. AND YOUR COMMITTEE
TO APPROVE A B. TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
SARS THANK YOU FOR YOUR STORY-
SO LET'S SEE I'M A MODERATOR IF
WE HAVE- MISTER CARRO HOW TO
GET ON THE LINE FROM CALIFORNIA
WALKS WILL TRY ONE MORE TIME.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS IS
CATTLE HOW HE WOULD CALIFORNIA
LAW YES GO RIGHT AHEAD. OKAY
PERFECT SO MY NAME IS SCOTT HOW
TO EAT AN ANTI COEXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA WALK.
THE STATEWIDE VOICE FOR
PEDESTRIAN SAFETY WE ARE
COSPONSORING AT TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHT THE FREEDOM TO WALK BACK.
BECAUSE IT'S BASED ON OUR OVER
TWENTY YEARS OF WORK ACROSS THE
STATE WE HAVE LEARNED THAT LOW
INCOME BLACK INDIGENOUS AND
OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR CROSS THE
STREET SAFELY AND METHODICALLY
IN SOME LOCATIONS WHERE IT MAY
NOT CURRENTLY BE LEGAL TO
CROSS. TOO LITTLE OR NO
PEDESTRIAN INFRASTRUCTURE WE
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT. THIS BILL
BECAUSE ONE. BILL WOULD ADD THE-
OF COMMENT THE CASHIER
BEHAVIORS I WILL REMOVE FINE.
AND J. WALKING MON
DISPROPORTIONATELY TARGET BLACK
CALIFORNIANS TO THE POINT WHERE
SOME HAVE BEEN SERIOUSLY HURT.
OR INJURED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT PROMOTE
UNSAFE WALKING ESTROGENS ARE
ALREADY USING THEIR COMMON
SENSE TO CROSS THE STREET
SAFELY AND THIS BILL WILL JACK
LEGALIZE THOSE BEHAVIORS. THEY
STILL MAINTAINS EXISTING LAW
WHICH DOES NOT PERMIT CROSSING
WHEN THERE IS AN IMMEDIATE
HAZARD. TODAY WE ASK YOU TO BE
COURAGEOUS AND BOLD TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA A STATE THAT DOES
NOT TOLERATE RACIAL PROFILING
AND DOES NOT PERPETUATE
COLLAPSES THEM BY PUNISHING
THOSE WHO ONLY MOBILITY. OPTION
IS WALKING. HOW RIGHT OF IS
MEANT TO BE. FOR MORRIS JACK
MOTORISTS. PLEASE JOIN
CALIFORNIA WALKS OVER NINETY
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
WHO WANTS TO DECRIMINALIZE JAY
WALKING AND WHO BELIEVE IN
RACIAL JUSTICE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU IN IS HOW
TO GAIN WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AS WELL- SO NOW WE'VE
CONCLUDED- PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT MODERATOR TO HAVE
ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE IN
SUPPORT. OF AB TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE. ALL RIGHT AGAIN
CAN YOU. PUT YOURSELF IN QUEUE
TO GET COMMENT TO SUPPORT IT'S
ONE NINE ZERO. OUR FIRST LINE
IS SIXTY YET AGAIN LINE NUMBER
SIX ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NUMBER SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. RIGHT ONE MOMENT WE'LL GO
TO LINE NUMBER SIX BOARD PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE DO NOT CHECK. MY
NUMBER SIXTY FIVE AGAIN LINE
SIX FIVE. HELLO THIS IS RIO
SHARPEN ATTORNEY WITH THE
LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS OF THE FFA AREA WILL
CROWN CO SPONSORS OF AB. TWELVE
THIRTY EIGHT HE'S A PATIENT TO
A WALKING PACE AND- ACTUALLY
GIVEN THE PEOPLE OF COLOR. THEY
LIED TO PROTECT SCHOOL AND
SOMETIMES LIFE THREATENING
ENCOUNTERS WITH THE POLICE. AND
THEY STRADDLE PEOPLE WITH A MAN
THAT CAN LAST FOR YEAR- LOOK AT
THE DATA YOU'LL SEE THAT THESE
ENCOURAGE RACIALLY DISPARATE
ENFORCEMENT- AND- DEPORTATION
COUPLE HUNDRED DOLLARS THANK
YOU. AND THE DRIVER'S LICENSE
AND OTHER ISSUES SO PLEASE
SUPPORT AT TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND AT THIS TIME WE'RE JUST
TAKING ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF A B. TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT
WE'RE JUST. TAKING NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIX SIXTY
THREE AGAIN LINE SIX THREE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS EVERY MAN CAN
CALLING WITH VOICES FOR
PROGRESS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. WHEN I GO
ONLINE. THREE ZERO AGAIN LINE
NUMBER THREE ZERO GO AHEAD.
MICHAEL SCHNEIDER LOS ANGELES
BASED TREATS FOR ALL INSTRUCT
THE PORT. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. MY NUMBER FORTY
SIX LINE NUMBER FOUR SIX. BRIAN
HAS BEEN ON BEHALF OF WALK SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
ONE NUMBER SIXTY TWO AGAIN MY
NUMBER SIX TWO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
NOGUEIRA AND SUPPORT A B.
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. MY NUMBER
THIRTY THREE LINE NUMBER THREE
THREE. THANK YOU ALEX AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
ABIGAIL OTHERS I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER REPORT
THANK YOU. CORRECT MY NUMBER IS
FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS BUT THE FISH ON BEHALF
OF BY CULVER CITY A CHAPTER OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BICYCLE
COALITION- INSTRUCTS ACCORDED
TOP THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT AGAIN LINE
NUMBER FIVE EIGHT. HELLO THIS
IS ALLISON MACK'S CALIFORNIA'S
YOUR POLICY MANAGER WITH THE
CITY FOR A PARTNERSHIP. IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT WE DO HAVE TWO MORE
LINES WILL BE GET THEIR LINE
NUMBER ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT
IN LINE NUMBER SIX EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JACQUELINE FLORES
ENERGY CITY LAW CENTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AN ONLINE
NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN A LINE
NUMBER SIXTY GRAND I'M NOT
AROUND WE HAVE A CELL YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND SUPPORT.
AND THERE ARE NO MORE LAND TO
Q. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MODERATOR SO IT CAN UP WELL
ACTUALLY WE'VE CONCLUDED THE
CONFERENCE LINE AND SUPPORT SO
GO TO THE GALLERY ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHT IN THE GALLERY AT THIS
TIME. SEE NONE. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
SIXTY NINE. OKAY NOW WE'LL TAKE
IT TO THE OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE
A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION MR
STEVE FERRO- COMING TO US AGAIN
FROM THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR CHILDREN'S SAFETY AND
HEALTH- IN THE GALLERY THANK
YOU MR. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MY NAME IS STEVE BERYL ON THE
STATE PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
CHILDREN'S SAFETY AND HEALTH.
AND LIKE- MAYBE ONE TO TWO
THESE BILLS THAT ARE REMOVING
TRAFFIC SAFETY LAWS. DRAG KIDS
INTO A DANGEROUS SITUATION WE
NEED CHILDREN GROWING UP
UNDERSTANDING HOW TO
APPROPRIATELY GET THROUGH ARE
REALLY BUSY STREETS. AND THAT
IS AT THAT HEARING TWO RED
LIGHTS CROSSING AT THE
CROSSWALKS. NOT JAY WALKING.
AND OKAY I'M DONE PAYING
ATTENTION TO ALL THE PEDESTRIAN
TRAFFIC SAFETY LAWS. THIS BILL
DOESN'T EVEN ADDRESS THE
INEQUITIES. THE INEQUITIES OF
WE WANT TO ADDRESS THAT WE NEED
TO REMOVE THE BURDEN OF
CITATION DEBT THAT IS WEIGHING
HEAVILY ON UNFORTUNATELY. OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WE NEED
TO REMOVE THAT DEBT YOU HAVE TO
MAKE THAT BOLD STEP FIRST TO
WHITE THE PINK SLIP. WE WHEN WE
HAVE INEQUITIES IN THE BICYCLE.
HELMET VIOLATION LAW YEAH HI
FIND TICKETS WHAT WE DID IS WE
MADE THOSE FIX IT TICKETS. WE
CHANGED THE NATURE OF HOW WE
ENFORCE. THE THAT SAFETY LAW WE
NEED TO DO THE SAME THING WITH
OUR PEDESTRIAN SAFETY LAWS THEY
SHOULD NOT BE HIGH FINES SHOULD
BE FIX IT TICKETS MEANING. THE
COMMUNITY EDUCATES THOSE THAT
ARE STRUGGLING. TO ADHERE TO
THE PEDESTRIAN SAFETY. AND MAKE
FIX IT TICKETS WE ALSO NEED TO
REMOVE THE HIGH FINES IN MACOMB
VERY SMALL CIVIL FINES. BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE NEED TO
ALLOW US TO RAISE CHILDREN UP.
LEARNING HOW TO NAVIGATE BUSY
STREETS AND THERE SHOULD BE A
BILL THAT'S FOCUSED ON THE
ADULTS AND IT SHOULD BE FOCUSED
ON THE INEQUITIES THAT DOES NOT
BY THROWING OUT ALL THE
PEDESTRIAN SAFETY LAWS IS NOT
ADDRESSING INEQUITIES YOU STILL
LEAVE THE DEBT THERE. AND YOU
DO NOT HAVE ANYTHING CHANGING
HOW WE ENFORCE WHEN PEOPLE
INAPPROPRIATELY CONTINUED TO
ENGAGE IN YEAH- TRAFFIC AND
WALK THROUGH TRAFFIC
INAPPROPRIATELY. YOU NEED FIX
IT TICKETS YOU NEED EDUCATION
YOU DO NOT NEED HIGH FINES.
THANK YOU MR PERO QUE BELIEVE
THAT CONCLUDES OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION TO TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFYC.
NINE ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION. THE NUN THE
MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT BACK TO
YOU FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE. ALL
RIGHT IF YOU WISH TO PUT
YOURSELF AND YOUR REGULAR
COMMENT AT TWO ONE NINE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IN ONE BED IN THERE-
TO PUT YOURSELF THANK YOU FOR
COMMENT AND JUST ONE MOMENT.
HELLO ALL THAT UP THE LINE AT
NUMBER TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS CORY SELLS A LITTLE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTIVELY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. NOTHING
MORE POLITICAL ALLIES AT THIS
TIME PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
THANK YOU I THINK WE'VE
CONCLUDED SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE ANY
MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO ASK A
QUESTION SENATOR MEN. CAN I
JUST HAVE A SHORT STATEMENT
URGES I'D APPRECIATE THE INTENT
OF THIS BILL AND I'M CERTAINLY-
THE COMMENTS AROUND RACIAL
INEQUITIES ARE SOBERING AND
INSTANTLY IT WOULD SEEM TO BE
THE CASE THAT. DISPARATE
ENFORCEMENT OF JAYWALKING LAWS
IS IT SOMETHING WE ALL SEE WE
KNOW HAPPENS AND IT IS A
PROBLEM. I AM CONCERNED HOWEVER
WITH THE- UNIT THE PROBLEM OF
ADVERSE INCENTIVES IF WE CREATE
A LAW THAT AFFECTS FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE STATE.
WHAT IMPACT DOES THAT HAVE ON-
IF YOU KNOW THE WAY THAT PEOPLE
THINK ABOUT LAWS BECAUSE THE
AVERAGE PERSON IS JUST GOING TO
TAKE THIS AS AN AND I AND I
KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR TOOK
AMENDMENTS TO. TO TRY TO LIMIT
THE TYPES OF BEHAVIOR BUT I
THINK TO THE AVERAGE PERSON OUT
THERE THEY'RE JUST GOING TO
HEAR THAT OKAY WALKING IS NOW
LEGAL. AND I WORRY THAT THAT
MIGHT LEAD TO A LOT MORE
PEDESTRIAN DEATHS A LOT MORE-
PROBLEMATIC BEHAVIOR AND- YOU
GIVEN THE HIGH RATES OF
PEDESTRIAN FATALITIES WE
ALREADY HAVE IN THE STATE- YOU
KNOW I GUESS IF I HAVE A
QUESTION IT MIGHT BE A YOU
KNOW. IT WOULD THIS BE BETTER
AS AS A PILOT TO JUST GET MORE
DATA BECAUSE I DID SEE AN
ANALYSIS ONE OF THE- INONE OF
THE OPEN QUESTIONS IS WHAT WILL
THIS TYPE OF POLICY OR LEGAL
CHANGE WHAT EFFECT WOULD HAVE
ACROSS THE STATE- BUT BUT GIVEN
JUST WHAT A MASSIVE CHANGE THIS
IS. I'M GONNA HAVE TO STAY OFF
OF THIS PARTICULAR VOTE- WHILE
I DO RECOGNIZE. THAT THE VERY
WORTHWHILE INTENT BEHIND IT.
THANK YOU SENATOR MANIFEST AND
IF I MAY- THE AUTHOR DID TAKE
AN AMENDMENT ON PEDESTRIAN
SAFETY DATA WHICH IS CURRENTLY
NOT AS ROBUST AS IT COULD BE
NOW. THIS THIS WOULD BE A
BEFORE AND AFTER. THAT THE
SEVEN YEAR SUNSET- I'M SORRY IT
SHOULD BE EVERY YEAR BUT IT
WOULD GIVE US A GOOD LOOK AT
THE BEFORE AND AFTER. OF THIS.
WITH THE INPUT OR THE- OUTCOMES
WOULD BE OF THIS LAW- I WILL
ALSO SAY THAT THERE IS NO HARD
EVIDENCE ON JAY WALKING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AT ALL.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT SAYS THAT
IT SHOULD WHICH IT'S ATTRIBUTED
TO. PEDESTRIAN SAFETY IN A WAY
THAT- CREATES. ADDITIONAL UNDUE
BURDENS ON LIKE PEDESTRIAN
INJURED INJURIES OR FATALITIES
SO- JUST TO CLARIFY THAT BUT HE
DID TAKE AMENDMENTS IN THAT
REGARD AS WELL BUT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IF YOU'D LIKE TO. ADD TO
THAT OR YOU CAN ADD TO YOUR
CLOTHES. WHILE DISALLOWING MY
COMMENTS- WITH YOU MANAGER I
THINK HE SPOKE VERY ELOQUENTLY
BALLARD- I HAVE THE SAME
CONCERN ABOUT PEDESTRIAN SAFETY
BUT THAT'S WHY ALL THE
PEDESTRIAN GROUPS ARE WITH ME
THAT'S WHY CALIFORNIA WALKS
WITH ME. SAN FRANCISCO BOXES
WITH ME THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONSTANTLY ADVOCATING. FOR
PEDESTRIAN SAFETY AND
PEDESTRIAN ACCESS TO SAFE
ROADS. ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
EXACTLY IS SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. WHAT THEY SAY IS REDUCING
VEHICLE SPEED. SAVES LIVES
MAKING SURE WE OR BETTER
CROSSWALKS MAKING SURE WE HAVE
BETTER PEDESTRIAN ACCESS.
THAT'S WHAT. REALLY WILL SAVE
LIVES. IN REGARDS TO THE
OPPOSITION I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE ON REDUCING FINES THAT'S
WHY THIS BILL GETS RID OF
FINES. BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT ARBITRARY
ENFORCEMENT. IS REALLY. TAKEN
AWAY. SO AGAIN THIS BILL DOES
NOT PERMIT IT DOES NOT PERMIT-
SAFE CROSSING. SO IF THERE IS
AN IMMEDIATE HAZARD IN TERMS OF
VEHICLE WHICH IS COMING TOWARD
PEDESTRIANS. THE OFFICER
ABSOLUTELY HAS A RIGHT TO
STATE. THAT PARTICULAR
PEDESTRIAN SO. FAR CLARIFY.
TRIPPIN PLEASE BEEN SOME
MISSING NUMBERS ABOUT WHAT THE
IS IN ISN'T. AND WE'RE GOING.
MY GREAT CALL FROM ORANGE
COUNTY- I ACTUALLY DON'T THINK
THIS BILL WILL CHANGE BEHAVIOR
WHAT WHAT WE'LL DO. IS CHANGE
THE ARBITRARY ENFORCEMENT. OF
BEHAVIOR THAT IS ALREADY GOING
ON ALL ACROSS THE STATE AT THIS
VERY SECOND. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FIGURE I THINK IS SOMEONE A
REACTION ONE MORE QUESTION HERE
AND THEN WE'LL ALLOW YOU TO
WRAP UP SO IT'S A SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- AND I
ALSO. HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS AS
EXPRESSED HERE ALREADY. BUT I
YOU KNOW I DO BELIEVE THIS BILL
IS GOOD INTENTIONS AND I CAN
SEE- BASED ON THE A WITNESS I
SPOKE. OF THE HOMELESS
GENTLEMAN WHO SAIDTHAT IT
AFFECTED HIS ABILITY TO GET A
DRIVER'S LICENSE I DO BELIEVE
THAT. YOU KNOW THAT SHOULD NOT
BE THE CASE WE SHOULD FIGURE
OUT A WAY WHERE DOES AN IMPACT
ON SIBLEY TEND TO GET A
DRIVER'S LICENSE AND DRIVING
GET TO WHERE THEY NEED TO BE-
BUT I ALSO BELIEVE THAT. WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON HAVING SOME
KIND OF METRICS THAT SAYS. YOU
KNOW SOMEONE THAT HAS THE
ABILITY TO PAY COMPAY AND THOSE
THAT DON'T THERE SHOULD BE
OPTIONS. ARE OUT ON HOW O TAKE
CARE OF THAT INFECTION WITHOUT.
REALLY HAVING TO BE BOGGED DOWN
WITH DAD WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT I BELIEVE IT'S REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT. IT WILL BE.
EXTREMELY CONFUSING TO ARE YOU
SENT AGAIN I HAVE TO COME FROM
THE TEACHER PERSPECTIVE AND-
YOU KNOW SYSTEM PRINCIPAL RICE
ALL SHOWS OF OUR CHILDREN
CROSSING THE STREETS AT ANY
GIVEN TIME AND YOU KNOW I WAS
HAVING TO. MONITOR AND I'VE
SEEN MANY COLLISIONS OCCUR
EVEN. WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO BE
SAFE SO I BELIEVE THAT THIS
WILL SEND MIXED SIGNALS IT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT TO TEACH A
CHILD. YOU KNOW THIS IS BASED
ON WHAT THE BILL STATES I
BELIEVE YOU KNOW I WOULD BE IN
A FRACTION OF THERE'S IMMEDIATE
HAZARD. VERSUS NOT AND I THINK
THAT THAT'S TOO MUCH FOR A
CHILD TO BE ABLE TO COMPREHEND.
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT WE'VE
BEEN TEACHING ALL ALONG YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE TO GO TO A
CROSSWALK AND BE SAFE. SO I
AGAIN AS A TEACHER WHAT I'VE
SEEN IN ALL THE- NEAR MISSES I
THINK THAT THIS IS JUST GOING
TO CONFUSE OUR YOUTH AND I
STILL HAVE TO ADVOCATE FOR. OUR
CHILDREN THAT DON'T HAVE- THE
MENTAL CAPACITY OF TAKING THE
ONES THAT ARE REALLY YOUNG TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS AT THIS POINT I WILL
HAVE TO STAFF THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS IF NOT I WILL
CERTAINLY ADD MY THOUGHTS AS
WELL- CERTAINLY ALL THE
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS YOU'VE
TO TAKEN TO HEART I KNOW YOU.
WORKED WITH THIS COMMIT AND WE
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR DOING
SUPPORTERS- I LOOK AT THIS
VERY. DIFFERENTLY AS WELL
PEDESTRIAN INFRASTRUCTURES IN
EQUITABLE. ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION MOBILITY OPTIONS
ARE OFTEN LACKLUSTER IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AND THESE
ARE THE SAME COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE BEING CONTACTED BY POLICE.
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR ISSUES
OF JAY WALKING. WHERE THEY
MAYBE WALKING SAFELY IN AN
INTERSECTION. AT TEN. AGAIN
MAKE NO MISTAKE SAFETY IS FIRST
HERE AS AS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED. THERE IS HARD
EVIDENCE THAT UNFORTUNATELY
HAS- INFORMATION LIKE MY OWN
BACKYARD IN LONG BEACH WERE
THERE A LOT OF CONTACTS WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR PRIMARILY BLACK THE LONG
BEACH RESIDENTS WHO'VE BEEN
KIND CONTACTED BY BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR JAKE WALKING.
BUT THERE'S NO REAL HARD
EVIDENCE THAT JAY WALKING IS
ATTRIBUTED. TO PEDESTRIAN
INJURIES AND FATALITIES WE
DON'T HAVE THAT REPORT. SO THIS
WILL ALLOW WITH AMENDMENTS
TAKEN TO ADD THAT REPORTING SO
WE CAN ENSURE THAT IF THERE IS
A JAYWALKING ISSUE. THAT WE DO-
ADDRESS THAT BUT MORE OFTEN
THAN NOT IT'S FOR ISSUES
RELATED TO HOMELESSNESS.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AT CETERA AS IT
STANDS NOW FOR DATA. SO WITH
THAT- AGAIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
WORKING WITH OUR- OUR OFFICE I
WANT TO THANK THE- THE
SUPPORTERS IN OPPOSITION AS
WELL AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE
WITH ME GO AHEAD. PICNICKING
MANAGER REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR COMMENTS I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO ALIGN MY- BIKE MY CLOTHES
WITH YOUR COMMENTS AND JUST
REITERATE. THAT PEDESTRIAN
SAFETY THAT'S THE PARAMOUNT
THAT'S WHY THE PEDESTRIAN
SAFETY ORGANIZATIONS ARE ALL
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. NOT JUST.
NOT JUST A SOFT OPPOSE A SOFT
SUPPORT BUT ACTS COSPONSORS IN
AS MAJOR STAKEHOLDERS WITH THIS
LEGISLATION THAT'S WHY THEY ARE
ADVOCATING FOR THIS BILL UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AUTO
THANK YOU THANK YOU SOMEONE
MEMBER DO WE HAVE A MOTION. FOR
MOVED THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
FOR A B. TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT
MOVED BY SENATOR SKINNER.
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. THAT AGAINST
ALL ODDS HI THE DOLLARS HI IT'S-
HELEN HI HELEN HI BUT YOU LEFT.
LETTER BY LETTER HI TODAY'S HI
PATES III ONLY GO BELLY NO DOT.
HI WHERE. LET US KNOW WELL IT
IS NOW. WOMEN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN
HI THE BILL. SKINNER HI SKINNER
HI. HUMBERT YEAH LIKE US KEEP
ALL RIGHT LIKE LCI WE'LL KNOW
WILL NOW. STATES NOW. EIGHT
FOUR. OKAY THANK YOU LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU SOME
REMEMBER. ALL RIGHTS WE'VE
CONCLUDED OUR BILLS UP FOR
DISCUSSION ALL FIVE OF THEM ARE
COMPLETE- BUT WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND LIFT THE CALLS STARTING
WITH FILE ITEM. ARE ACTUALLY
STARTING WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT IF WE CAN START
THERE AND AGAIN THIS IS- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO READ THE CONSENT
BILLS. NOT I HAVE THEM HERE
IT'S EIGHTY SIX OH FOUR DAILY.
AC ARE NINETEEN GALLAGHER. ACR
TWENTY ONE MEGAN DELI IS C. R.
TWENTY SEVENTH GALLAGHER. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE CHAIR
AND THE VICE CHAIR BOTH VOTING
HI ALAN. HI HELEN HI DOT. HI
WHERE. BLENDERS BLENDERS HIGH
MEDIA RUBIO HI SKINNER SKINNER
HI BUT CASKEY HI KELSEY HI.
SIXTEEN VOTES OKAY SIXTEEN AND
I BELIEVE ARE WE WAITING FOR
ONE OTHER MEMBER TO COME BACK
TO THE WAR ON THE WIRE OKAY
GREAT. A RATE- NEXT FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BY BURNER FOR ABOUT. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR
VOTING HI THE VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING. BUT IT'S. ELLEN HI
ELLEN HI. SKINNER SKINNER I
BOOK WELCOME HI. FOURTEEN TWO
OKAY FOURTEEN TO AT THIS MOMENT
WE'RE WAITING FOR SENATOR
MCGUIRE TO COME BACK. BUT
WITHOUT IT OKAY FOURTEEN TO THE
BILL IS OUT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BURNER FOR ABOUT. ALL RIGHT-
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY SIX
OH FOUR BY I'M SORRY A. B. FILE
ITEM THREE MY APOLOGIES AB
EIGHT ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REBUS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR
PULLED VOTING HI. HELEN ELLEN
HI WHERE BY WIRE HI SKINNER
SKINNER I WILL WELCOME BYE.
SEVENTEEN VOTES SEVENTEEN ALL
RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT. X. FILE
ITEM FOR AB NINE SEVENTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR
VOTING BY THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO. ALAN HI ALAN HI BETTER
WRITE BETTER HI. WHERE HI GLARE
HI SKINNER HI. I WELL I WILL HI.
FOURTEEN THREE OKAY THAT BILL
IS OUT. NEXT FILE ITEM FIVE
EIGHTY NINE FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD. THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY THAT YOU'RE VOTING HI
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NOW.
GLARE BY GLARE HI. SKINNER BY
SKINNER I BUY CASKET CASKEY I
WILL. WE'LL KNOW. THIRTEEN FOUR
OKAY THANK YOU THAT PHYLLIS OUT
LAST BILL FILE ITEM SIX A. B.
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
I THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
ARCHULETA MCGUIRE HI BLAIR HIGH
MAN. RUBIO NUMBER. K. NINE FOUR
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT GREAT SO
THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA FOR
TODAY THE ONE TO THANK YOU ALL
ARE TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY I'M SORRY. WE
HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MY APOLOGIES THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ONE MORE TIME
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THE CHAIR AND
THE VICE CHAIR BOLD VOTING
HIGH. WIRE I THINK YOU ARE.
SEVENTEEN BOOKS ARE RIGHT THAT
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE. OKAY
NOW WE CONCLUDE OUR AGENDA
THANK YOU TO ALL INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS WE
THINK YOU'D APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND- THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION IS
ADJOURNED HAVE A GREAT DAY.